d'agir et de travailler ensemble car dès
lors bien sûr la bretagne à cinq
départements non seulement c'est le sens
de l'histoire mais en plus c'est urgent
parce qu'en termes de développement de
territoire c'est un enjeu très important
je vis dans le pays de redon ce cette
frontière administrative qui fait
souffrir la cohérence des territoires la
cohérence sociale culturelle économique
je la vis au quotidien donc
effectivement il est temps de résoudre
cette problématique il est temps de
prendre cette problématique à bras le
corps et je souhaite que nous ayons dans
la séquence à venir la séquence régional
et la séquence présidentielle
les moyens de deux mètres des
fédéralistes en responsabilité est de
permettre de ré agencer les territoires
en fonction de la réalité des bassins de
vie de la réalité des destins communs
des territoires oui moi je suis
favorable vous rappelle que nous sommes
la liste droite centre et régionaliste
mais les vieux ne suffisent plus on a
rencontré dans le cadre de cette
campagne les associations qui militent
depuis des années alors vous le dites
vous même et vous fait le constat de
l'échec de ces dernières années à la
bretonne et bretagne réunie qui nous ont
demandé aux uns et aux autres comment on
allait procéder pour un concrètement
donc en capacité de ramener j'aime bien
l'expression vous avez employé la loire
atlantique dans la bretagne
moi je les dis je pense que ça passe par
une consultation bien évidemment des
habitants de la loire-atlantique qu'on
voudra il faudra suivre leur leur
décision si ils disent qu'ils souhaitent
se rattacher à la bretagne
et ça passera par une loi voilà une loi
donc nous on a commencé à y travailler
j'ai déjà dit qu'il y aura une vice
présidente à la région bretagne qui sera
nommé qui travaillera là dessus parce
que oui il faut s'en occuper
les seuls mots ne suffisent plus
aujourd'hui ça demandera du temps parce
qu'il faudra convaincre
et moi j'aimerais on est sur ce sujet là
la capacité de faire voter une loi
bretagne qui permettra également de
d'introduire la notion d'assemblée
unique de bretagne dont pour nous
l'assemblée unique de bretagne elle est
à 5 ans une dernière juste petite
question pour ou contre les historiens
pour ou contre pour grandes éoliennes
monsieur plenel assez facile
entre 0h à la fois très rapidement à la
fois en mer et sur la terre ce sont des
catastrophes écologiques qui menacent la
biodiversité qui gâchent la vie des
ruraux qui qui sont pleines de nuisance
et donc moi je suis je suis probablement
le seul candidat est totalement opposés
à l'éolien parce que en plus ça enrichit
les multinationales contre trévise
là je donc je suis content voilà j'ai
déjà je suis pour mais il ya un sujet
d'acceptation sociale et on voit bien
que quand les projets d'éoliennes sont
portés par des collectifs ça marche très
bien quand c'est porté par des
multinationales effectivement ça génère
des tensions dans le territoire il faut
travailler sur cette acceptation sociale
il faut le faire pour toutes les
énergies renouvelables y compris la
méthanisation
vous avez du retard tient évidemment au
support mais faut pas se tromper
les projets individuels enfin les
projets participatifs comme on dit bon
papa de problème évidemment puisque les
gens contribuent mais là il s'agit pas
ça il s'agit d'un parc éolien en baie de
saint brieuc 2 500 mégawatts
on se bat on peut pas imaginer un tel
investissement avec des financements
participèrent cela dit ce dock mais si
vous venez de le dire nous attendons
maintenant je défends donc il faut du
courage il faut du courage et et la
région dans ce dossier depuis quelque
temps elle est absente
c'est ça c'est fort regrettable c'est en
tout cas son jeu attendez mais en tout
cas on change le cas en tout cas en tout
cas c'est un sujet d'importance dans la
région bretagne qui je le rappelle des
bons à 85% de l'extérieur dans sa
dépendance énergétique
donc il nous faut des actes et projets
d'envergure mais on doit les mener avec
les pêcheurs et pas contre eux mais ils
avaient le callennec abat sur quinze
éoliennes ma surprise en monsieur burlot
il a été cinq ans dans la majorité
depuis cinq mois il critique monsieur
chesnais girard et
ces cinq derniers jours ont essayé de
lui tendre la main moi je suis contre ce
projet de parc éolien en baie de
saint-brieuc et je suis étonnée je suis
étonné vous êtes président de l' agence
nationale de la biodiversité que vous ne
trouviez rien à redire à ce projet qui
va détruire la ressource halieutique qui
risque de mettre au chômage 9 300
pêcheurs c'est de la pêche artisanale
ces hauts lieux de la vie des pêcheurs
très fier d'avoir sur ma liste des
pêcheurs qui effectivement se bat depuis
des mois pour que ce projet ne se fasse
pas tout jeune élu par françois fillon
exactement exactement rappelons nous
quand même l'effet sur le sujet monsieur
sarkozy il n'y a attribué à iberdrola
monsieur fillon qui a décidé exactement
wallemme le callennec gear lors d'un
débat nous a dit il faudra du courage
mais son courage aujourd'hui il est où
le courage de dire enfin les deux noms
des défunts
alors que là elle est typiquement vous
l'avez
madame vos amis qui ont imposé ce projet
donc je nous sommes évidemment pour les
énergies renouvelables que ce soit
l'éolien le solaire les les innovations
qui peuvent avoir lieu sur l'utilisation
des énergie de la houle ou démarrer on a
là on a un potentiel énorme en bretagne
on a la responsabilité authier de capter
cette ressource qui vient sur notre
territoire
donc d'en faire un outil d'autonomie
énergétique et de capter aussi la valeur
ajoutée qui est lié à la fois en termes
de création d'emplois et en termes de
création de richesses à la captation de
ces énergies renouvelables donc oui oui
oui on veut des énergies renouvelables
non on ne veut pas de la centrale à gaz
de l'indivision on ne veut pas de
solutions du passé pour assurer
l'autonomie énergétique de la région et
on veut les économies d'énergie c'est
important l'avenir énergétique de la
bretagne passe par l'autonomie par lise
les énergies renouvelables et par les
économies d'énergie
on veut rénover cinquante mille
logements par an sur la séquence du
mandat pour réduire nos besoins et se
concentrer sur des énergies
renouvelables bien entrée dans les
territoires et des projets ambitieux
même si bien sûr il ya des conditions et
des clauses pour que ça se passe
je pense qu'une question de dialogue et
de médiation aujourd'hui qui doit être
mis en place mais ne vous inquiétez pas
madame les callennec au danemark en
suède où le ou la poche ou la pêche se
porte très bien
il ya déposé sur le reste de délits
batteur édito avant de passer j'aimerais
fonder le temps quand même pour que vous
puissiez nous expliquer pourquoi voter
pour votre liste et surtout nous dire où
vous souhaitez a mené dimanche prochain
cette bretagne dans les vertus n'y un
édito avec vous la saint jean les
fictions emparé de la tension attention
c'est terrible il ya plus de 65% les
bretons qui sont pas allés voter ça
représente 1,6 million bretons qui sont
pas allés aux urnes dimanche et 85% des
jeunes
j'ai beau lire l'éditorial de françois
xavier le franc qui est le rédacteur en
chef de ouest france il a écrit à la une
mardi
nous marchons sur la tête je vais vous
dire juste quelques lignes et après vous
allez répondre nous étions dimanche
appelé à voter pour élire les
conseillers régionaux avec des listes
départementales
au moment même où nous devrions élire
des conseillers départementaux mais
cette fois sans listes départementales
avec des binômes par canton pourquoi y
at il deux collectivités qu'est la
différence entre les deux qui fait quoi
qui décide quoi comment s'y retrouver
quand
l'une et l'autre intervienne dans le
domaine de l'enseignement de
l'environnement et du transport qui
comprend à part nous vous est ce que
c'est une raison de l'abstention est ce
qu'il faut pas moderniser tout ça est
arrêté ces empilements de strates
isabelle le callennec merci à monsieur
le franc de rappeler qu'il y avait une
réforme qui avait été votée en 2010 qui
instituait le conseiller territorial moi
j'y suis favorable je souhaite que
l'année prochaine dans la campagne de la
présidentielle
on y reviennent parce que ce conseiller
territorial il siège à la fois sur les
questions qui concernent le département
et les questions qui concernent la
région
on n'en peut plus de ce millefeuille
politico administratif les électeurs et
les électrices n'y comprennent plus rien
donc oui évidemment il faut faire
évoluer les choses et c'est aussi la
raison pour laquelle je souhaite une
assemblée unique de bretagne
clément bien sûr nous défendons
l'assemblée de bretagne c'est un sujet
que l'udb notamment qui est membre de
notre coalition a porté très fort sur
les dix dernières années c'est essentiel
aujourd'hui ce mode de scrutin qui est
le résultat du travail de dix ans de
détricotage et de bidouillages
politiques notamment par le parti
socialiste sur ces questions là c'est
scandaleux fin clairement personne ne
comprend ce mode de scrutin et personne
ne comprend après la loi notre la
réorganisation des compétences donc on a
besoin de clarifier on a besoin de
coordonner je pense que c'est vraiment
très important le rôle de la région
c'est d'être un coordinateur de l'action
des territoires on a des départements où
et qui fonctionne différemment et la
région qui doit mener une politique de
coordination ça ne peut pas fonctionner
il faut revenir à une assemblée unique
qui a un vrai pouvoir de décision et de
captation de la ressource aussi je le
dise est important de tenir ça passe par
des moyens thierry burlot moi je suis
favorable à cette collectivité unique et
je partage eux c'était évidemment un
mois je constate que c'est encore ce
qu'on a le mieux voter avons fait
appeler et c'est là bas qu'on a une
collectivité unique
donc j'en ai envie de devenir aspirant
nous mais mais moi je me mets à la place
des électeurs que j'ai rencontrés avec
vous d'ailleurs en fallait qu'on a tous
rencontrés ils n'y comprennent rien et
c'est ça la rejeta aujourd'hui ils n'y
comprennent rien et et moi je me mets à
leur place ça a été difficile alors vous
imaginez
dimanche dernier 13 listes 13 listes
donc c'est pas si elle va continuer à
tenter fini c'est pas fini non j'avais
jamais 1 2
de travers il ya deux travers qu'il faut
les jt jour il voulait c'est aussi
pourquoi voter pour lui sinon vous
n'aurez pas le temps de colmater
continue de tourner il ya deux travers
qu'il faut éviter la aujourd'hui le
conseil régional est trop perçu comme un
outil au service de la métropole
rennaise mais c'est comme ça vous savez
c'est terry mais c'est comme ça houle
avait soudain mais laissez moi finir
c'est terrible mais c'est comme ça donc
je suis assez d'accord avec madame le
callennec je trouve que l'idée du
conseiller territorial sais pas si c'est
pas si idiot que ça mais il faut aussi
de la proportionnelle donc il faudrait
il faudrait sans doute et faudrait sans
doute qu'on puisse allier les deux du
territoire et de la proportionnelle mais
sur la collectivité unique je trouve que
c'est une bonne idée mais la
proportionnelle par tous effectivement
dès comprend plus rien du tout les gens
savent plus qui fait quoi
mais ça c'est le résultat de la
politique les lois de décentralisation
qui ont été votées à la fois par la
gauche et la droite qui ont superposé
tous ces échelons de collectivités il
faut effectivement simplifier tout ça
simplifier tout ça le département doit
perdurer en tant qu'entité
administrative lieu de l'autorité du
préfet ses compétences aujourd'hui très
réduit doivent passer effectivement la
région mais je rappellerai que
l'abstention elle a aussi d'autres
raisons
c'est aussi le dégoût de la politique
par le spectacle qui est donné des
tripatouillages auquel on assiste en
bretagne très récemment et c est cette
abstention c'est aussi parce qu'on n'a
pas la proportionnelle parce que les
gens se sont plus représentées quand ils
votent ils se sont par eux ils sont pas
représentés donc il faut effectivement
une collectivité unique en bretagne son
pouvoir législatif c'est avec une
proportionnelle où tous les bretons sont
représentés girard je voudrais dire très
fraternel nous reste à 3 minutes pour
conclure je voudrais dire très
fraternellement à 15m employés il faut
pas se tromper d'adversaire
c'est la droite l'adversaire c'est pas
la gauche bon concernant monsieur pennel
votre parti veut supprimer les régions
sous forme et vous comptez donc il faut
être un peu cohérent très partagés
ensemble et je partage le projet de
l'assemblée de bretagne mais il faut
rester sur des listes proportionnel pour
que chacun sont représentés la liste
scrutin uninominal c'est pas la bonne
solution il faut que chacun soit
représentée dans l'hémicycle on est à
1h26
de néma on va peut-être vous montrer les
temps de parole respectifs
nous allons passer vraiment est ce qui
nous reste 30 secondes chacun ou sommes
en direct simultané sur public sénat et
tvr on va vous demander de nous dirons
souhaitez vous entraîner pour les 20 ans
à venir en étant élu dimanche prochain
pour notre bretagne et là il y un petit
jingle régional 2021 qui ne vient pas et
bien écoutez vous m'a gagné du temps on
va démarrer avec vous il avait le
callennec qui sont ô la bretagne
moi j'espère que dans sept ans on aura
prouvé en bretagne on est capable de
concilier le développement économique la
protection de notre environnement et la
cohésion sociale et qu'on aura été
capables de voter pour une femme
ce sera une grande première en région
bretagne vous merci bretagne d'avenir
plutôt moi je pense qu'on est à l'aube
d'une dune vraiment d'une nouvelle donne
politique en bretagne j'appelle tous les
bretonnes et les bretons qui ont envie
de se rassembler autour des valeurs de
l'écologie de la gauche du fédéralisme à
nous rejoindre à faire en sorte que nous
puissions écrire cette nouvelle étape
que nous puissions porter une bretagne
d'avenir notre intime conviction c'est
que l'écologie c'est l'avenir de la
bretagne et on invite tous à deux et
ceux à qui ce qu'ils veulent sincèrement
ce changement à nous rejoindre et à
voter pour bretagne d'avenir ce dimanche
si l'on voit trop conclusions mais
écoutez moi je pense que la bretagne est
une terre de compromis et la liste nous
la bretagne et basse et cela c'est la
capacité de travailler les uns avec les
autres
ne pas opposer les agriculteurs les
pêcheurs aux associations de protection
de l'environnement de faire ensemble et
c'est ça le projet que je veux porter et
rien que ça et est ce qu'ils disent oui
à la fd soi sans discussion non il faut
faire ensemble
le cnra enfin je veux bien entendu une
bretagne qui garde ses sourires des
sourires sa jeunesse et sourire de
toutes ces générations je veux une
bretagne qui garde son identité je veux
une bretagne qui protège qui protège les
individus les hommes les femmes qui
vivent mais aussi son environnement
je vais une bretagne dynamique vivante
solidaire je veux une bretagne qui
continue sa marche vers les transitions
c'est cela que je propose c'est pour ça
que je propose de continuer à me donner
de la force à leur place en tête au
premier tour a été un honneur il faut me
donner l'énergie par le deuxième tour en
votant pour la liste la bretagne avec
loïc jean bédel 30 secondes grand
maximum je veux dire aux bretons que
s'abstenir c'est favoriser ceux qui sont
responsables de nos problèmes et qui
sont au pouvoir
un jeu propose un projet complètement
différent de mes concurrents une
bretagne forte forte dans son économie
forte dans son identité identité menacée
je le répète par l'immigration et par
l'islamisme et je pèse mes mots
une bretagne équilibré où il fasse bon
vivre en sécurité et en prospérité
merci beaucoup avec rien mancini de
public sénat et à vincent jarnigon de
ouest france était vert on vous remercie
pour ce débat parfois un peu passionné
mais passionnant en tout cas merci à
vous tous merci d'avoir suivi en direct
ce débat simultanément sur les chaînes
et les antennes de thé vert et public
sénat merci à son président christopher
baldelli
en tout 1 doha grand plaisir à vous
retrouver sur nos nos antennes
respectives pour vous faire vivre
dimanche soir cette soirée d'élection
nous irons l'espacé à partir de 19h
45 en vous accueillant bien évidemment
tous les cinq
merci en tout cas à tous très belle
journée à vous et merci pour ce débat
pour cette région bretagne
[Musique]
public sénat en partenariat avec tv
rennes et ouest france vous a présenté
régional 2021
le débat bretagne voilà pour ce débat de
l'entre-deux tours des élections
régionales en bretagne un débat diffusé
en partenariat avec tv air et ouest
france je vous rappelle que le second
tour des élections régionales et
départementales a lieu partout en france
dimanche prochain
tout de suite les questions au
gouvernement
[Musique]
très heureux de vous retrouver pour le
moment fort du mercredi au sénat les
questions au gouvernement
à 15 heures les sénateurs vont
interroger les ministres sur les sujets
d'actualité du moment et on va vous
faire vivre cette séance avec toute
notre équipe est d'abord notre
commentateur situé en tribune de presse
de l'hémicycle du sénat
jérôme rabier quel va être le programme
aujourd'hui ou parler des élections
régionales et départementales de
l'abstention qui a marqué le premier
tour des dysfonctionnements aussi dans
la distribution des professions de foi
des candidats et même une question sur
la nécessité ou non d'un front
républicain
mais ces élections c'est le sujet du
jour nous serons aussi en salle des
conférences du sénat avec notre
interview heures quand un call mais qui
va recueillir les réactions des
sénateurs des ministres quentin qui
aurait vous à votre micro et bien alex
bonjour effectivement dans une dizaine
de minutes on va recevoir ici philippe
bas on va revenir sur cette audition de
gérald darmanin sur le dysfonctionnement
dans la distribution d'un coupon monde
et puis vers 14h40 on aura tony
estanguet à notre micro pour parler de
la journée de l'olympisme
alex 1 et enfin comme chaque semaine
nous serons avec le streamer politique
jean massiet qui va commenter cette
séance sur la plateforme switch avec
toute sa communauté
salut gens commencent à voir à lui alex
ça va très bien et coûtent on a très
hâte de voir ce que vont poser comme
question les sénateurs et sénatrices
quelques jours seulement avant le second
tour des élections régionales
mais à 14h30 on parlera de la loi climat
examiné en ce moment au sénat et on se
posera une question faut-il supprimer
certaines lignes aériennes où il existe
une alternative en train en moins de 2
heures 30 ce sera l'objet notre de notre
face à face entre le sénateur les
républicains bruno belin et le sénateur
écologiste
ronan dantec mais d'abord on va
s'intéresser aux élections régionales et
départementales et au fiasco de
l'organisation du premier tour beaucoup
d'électeurs n'avaient pas reçu les
professions de foi des candidats est les
bulletins de vote
alors le ministre l'intérieur a dû
s'expliquer ce matin devant les
sénateurs pour en parler j'accueille sur
ce plateau
sophie taille et polluant sénatrice
écologiste du val de marne jean raymond
hugonnet sénateurs l'est républicain de
l'essonne et ludovic est sénateur du
groupe r des pays à la république en
marche du haut rhin bonjour à tous les
trois avant d'ouvrir le débat sur cette
organisation défaillante du premier tour
on va regarder ce qui s'est dit dans
l'audition du ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin les explications de ces
celtics ont des cartons entiers non
distribué des enveloppes éparpillés en
pleine nature ou encore brûlés le
président de la commission des lois
françois noël buffet a diffusé des
photos pour illustrer ce qu'il qualifie
de fiasco et posé une question à gérald
darmanin
pourquoi des milliers de français n'ont
pas reçu la propagande électorale avant
le premier tour le ministre de
l'intérieur avance plusieurs raisons
la concomitance de deux élections les
difficultés d'accès à certains logements
mais incrimine surtout adrexo l'une des
sociétés prestataires chargés de la
distribution
plusieurs raisons ont été apportées par
société adrexo vous les avoir pas vu
médiatiquement il reconnu manifestement
men attaque informatique qui l'ont pas
son passé par beaucoup de vacataires
peut-être que ce marché était finalement
trop gros pour eux autre questionnement
des sénateurs ce matin cette non
distribution des professions de foi at
elle joué sur l'abstention
nous avons beaucoup de témoignages de
gens qui ne sont pas allés voter
simplement parce qu'ils n'avaient pas
reçu cette probable quand la question de
la perte de chance va se poser il est
vrai que les 32 millions de français qui
ne sont pas allés voter ne sont pas
allés voter uniquement pour
cette question technique est ce que vous
considérez que la sincérité du scrutin
est entaché haut mais pour gérald
darmanin
cela n'a rien changé il ya plusieurs
jurisprudences du conseil d'état qui
évoque des distributions non distribués
du tout des communes qui paraît en tout
j'ai rappelé commune d'annecy par
exemple qu'il avait eu aucune propagande
et le conseil d'état a toujours
considéré qu'il ne s'agissait pas de
difficultés profondes de sincérité du
scrutin
au total selon le ministre 9% du
matériel électoral n'a pas été distribué
au premier tour il promis aux
parlementaires de faire mieux
avant le second tour je crois que les
sociétés font aujourd'hui le maximum et
singulièrement la société adrexo qui est
la plus concernée pour améliorer la
distribution de la propagande il est
évident qu'il n'y aura pas 100%
distribution de propagande pour dimanche
prochain en trois jours le ministre de
l'intérieur prendra des sanctions après
le second tour
la commission des lois du sénat
continuera elle ses auditions dans les
semaines à venir sous forme de
commission denquête ce qui lui permettra
d'interroger l'ensemble des responsables
sofitel et polluant est ce que vous êtes
convaincus par les explications du
ministre sur ce fiasco de l'organisation
du premier tour - effectivement je
reprends à mon compte ce terme de fiasco
at on jamais vu chose pareille et une
double élection on a déjà connu et non
et normalement les choses doivent être
réglées au millimètre pour cela ça fait
partie de deux des fondamentaux quand on
reçoit son enveloppe chez soi et qu'on
ne soutient pas forcément extrêmement
informés de la vie politique on se dit
ah oui il y à une élection on a la
capacité de pouvoir étaler sur sa table
l'intégralité des propositions dans
l'égalité et donc c'est vraiment un
moment clé pour beaucoup de françaises
et de français pour regarder faire le
point se dire bon réfléchir
tranquillement
donc c'est vraiment un outil clé moi je
trouve que le
le ministre de l'intérieur prend ça avec
beaucoup de légèreté en disant quelques
couacs non je veux dire c'est vraiment
ça fait vraiment partie des
responsabilités de son ministère que
d'organiser ces élections les élections
et là les professions de foi les
bulletins sont des éléments fondamentaux
les professions de foi sont des éléments
fondamentaux de choix pour les
électrices et les électeurs surtout en
cette période compliquée ils auraient
été en fait il était indispensable que
ces éléments fondamentaux soient
vraiment au contraire soigner encore
davantage que d'habitude
ludovic est est-ce qu'on peut parler de
fiasco de l'organisation de ce premier
tour
ou est ce que c'est un simple quoique
d'organisation souple et on peut jouer
sur les mots aujourd'hui force est de
constater qu'il ya eu des
dysfonctionnements qui ont peut-être été
amplifiés j'apprenais petite correction
des double scrutin comme ce qu'on a pu
connaître en a pas eu depuis n'est 186
souvent parlé de venir dont le avoir des
superpositions partiel avec des sédatifs
anticipé ou des choses mais des scrutins
vraiment en plein départementaux et
régionaux en même temps c'était une
première après ça n'explique pas que
l'entreprise et les entreprises
en l'occurrence de distribution est
connu des dysfonctionnements aujourd'hui
moi ce que je voudrais distinguer c'est
les deux catégories d'un
dysfonctionnement il ya celui qu'on a
déjà connu par le passé là aujourd'hui a
beaucoup d'états de qu'ils font il ya eu
beaucoup de sujets notamment sur l'axé
des immeubles collectifs qui sont
sécurisées avec grille de problème de
clefs universel quand les facteurs mais
que n'avait pas de réseau etc
ce sont des problèmes qu'on avait connu
par le passé qu'ils mériteraient
aujourd'hui simplement de trouver une
vraie solution est pour des scrutins de
dimanche mais aussi pour les scrutins à
venir et ne pas recréer n'ont plus de
feuilles de sécurité parce qu'à terme si
c'est si ces logements collectifs sont
sécurisées ce n'est peut-être pas non
plus pour que tout le monde est une clé
universelle
ça c'est le premier point b hamon qui
était méconnu parce que ce sont des
personnes effectivement qui n'était pas
du territoire là encore une fois faut
s'appuyer sur les territoires les
personnes qui connaissent des personnes
qui sont à la maison et il ya une vraie
justification et il ya eu un phénomène
d'amplification sur ce scrutin là
effectivement
et si encore une fois il faut bien faire
distinction entre les bulletins qui
n'auraient pas été les professions de
foi qui n'auraient pas été distribuées
de manière involontaire est celle qui
l'on est et qui ont été jetés la nature
sciemment ou là c'est une faute et qu'il
s'agira de condamner après le second
tour
bien sûr car
on a vu dans certains témoignages des
professions de foi je t'ai brûlé à
l'orée de certains bois gens vraiment le
gone et qu'est ce que vous pensez de ces
failles dans l'organisation de ce
premier tour sur la propagande
électorale déjà dans un premier temps je
veux saluer l'initiative du président de
la commission des lois qui a demandé
très rapidement à ce que le ministre
soit auditionné au sénat
encore une fois la seconde gg pu suivant
budgétés en commission mais j'ai suivi
un petit peu cette audition le ministre
de l'intérieur était déjà tendue et
quand on se permet de dire à philippe
bas qu'il dit bien qu'il dit des bêtises
je pense que c'est une phrase qu'il va
regretter
à un moment donné plus plus sérieusement
ça montre à quel point l'état est dans
un état de déliquescence
la démocratie ce sont des élections
c'est même le point d'orgue qui permet
de s'exprimer et démocratiquement de
choisir qui va diriger telle ou telle
structure l'état une fois de plus et
absent au rendez vous rendez vous compte
quand même
rendez vous compte l'état dans lequel
nous sommes là ce sont des élections et
c'est la démocratie qui se joue
maintenant je veux dire une chose le
point de départ de tout cela c'est quoi
c'est pas des détails techniques c'est
pas tout le monde
tout le monde va voir ses arguments ce
ne sont pas des arguments là on parle
après la fumée des cierges
c'est là sur transposition d'une
directive européenne en 2005 qui donne à
la propagande électorale le fait de
rentrer dans le secteur marchand
le problème il est là et tout le monde
sait quand on est élu local que
attribuer un marché à une entreprise qui
est à 20% en dessous du prix elle va pas
vous donner ce le service que vous
attendez et quand on pense que l'état a
laissé faire ça
là on a de quoi s'interroger c'est
encore une fois un signe de
déliquescence profonde de l'état
on va en parler de cette mise en
concurrence de la distribution de la
propagande électorale
mais d'abord je voudrais évoquer à la
commission d' enquête parlementaire qui
a été annoncé par le président du sénat
gérard larcher on va l'écouter il était
ce matin chez nos confrères de lci
vous dites c'est le rôle du parlement
que de contrôler
l'action de l'exécutif il ya
manifestement une insuffisance bien le
parlement va contrôler et notamment le
sénat c'est notre fonction
constitutionnel jeudi en séance nous
déclencherons la commission d' enquête
qui sera portée par la commission des
lois
c'est tout simple c'est la fonction du
parlement en sofitel et polluant elle
est utile cette commission d' enquête
parlementaire du sénat pour faire toute
la lumière sur ce qui ne s'est pas bien
passé dans cette distribution de
propagande électorale
bien sûr c'est effectivement je rejoins
complètement le président larcher
je pense que c'est effectivement un de
nos rôles les plus importants que de
contrôler l'exécutif et donc c'est
parfaitement là si on est parfaitement
dans notre rôle est dans notre note de
voir même après je voudrais rebondir sur
ce qu'a dit mon collègue hugo n'est je
pense effectivement que la question
c'est de savoir qu'est ce qui relève du
service public et comment aujourd'hui en
libéralisant en mettant les choses en
concurrence avec des entreprises qu'on
pressure pressure près sur la poste
aussi a connu des défaillances dans
cette dans cette distribution
on en arrive là le service public vous
savez c'est aussi des agents qui ont des
statuts je dirais a suffisamment solides
pour pour avoir le sens de l'intérêt
général qui fait partie de leur lors de
leur état d'esprit quand on a des
vacataires qui dit toute manière c'est
pas grave je serai pas réembauché demain
donc il n'ya pas il n'ya pas l'amour de
la belle ouvrage voyez il n'y a pas le
sens de l'intérêt général
peut-on les en blâmer alors que on les
prend on les jette et que ce sont eux
les variables d'ajustement des baisses
de prix je ne suis pas sur le service
public et on doit s'interroger et tous
les jours dans les territoires on
s'interroge quand on a des bureaux de
postes qui disparaissent ou dont les
horaires se rétrécissent sur le rôle la
place de la poste à la fois en tant que
distributeur de courrier mais aussi par
rapport à ses compétences bancaire dans
nos territoires et là on a typiquement
et bien écoutez le dysfonctionnement
majeur de cette vision extrêmement
libérale
nous nous avons notre vision française
du service public qu'il conviendrait de
remettre vraiment au centre des projets
politiques
ludovic est pour faire toute la lumière
sur tout ce système de distribution de
la propagande électorale et ce qu'il
faut une commission d' enquête du sénat
vous êtes favorable d'abord le sujet de
la mission d'information avait été
évoqué dans un de prime abord et je
crois que l'on se dirige peut-être sur
une mission d'information qui prendra
des caractères effectivement de tout cas
c'est ce qu'on m'a dit récemment
très récemment ce matin j'étais la
commission des lois effectivement pour
auditionner le ministre de l'intérieur
et je tiens à dire que effectivement
notre collègue philippe bas a souligné
en dix ans lorsque les entreprises
doivent répondre à un appel d'offres
elles suivent un cahier des charges et
philippe bas s'étaient étonnés de se
dire est ce que le cahier des charges
n'était pas finalement peut-être un peu
trop léger par rapport à ce qu'il aurait
été demandée moi je dis que c'est aussi
un rôle d entreprise lorsqu'on répond à
un appel d'offres il faut être en mesure
de l'honorer
c'est pas le tout de l'obtenir il faut
être en mesure de l'honorer et vous
évoquiez chers collègues les le
recrutement de vacataires etc
c'est un pic c'est un pic de charge pour
des activités pour des entreprises qui
n'ont pas l'habitude de travailler de
manière aussi intense s'annonce à ça ça
s'anticipe ça s'anticipe voilà et là
force est de constater que
l'anticipation n'a pas eu lieu donc
aujourd'hui encore une fois il faut
s'organiser
je vais vous prendre un exemple très
concret lorsque vous allez acheter une
voiture chez un concessionnaire
il n'a pas en l'idée de vous livrer un
demi véhicules ou encore des véhicules
il vous donnera des délais de livraison
il vous dira si c'est possible
immédiatement ou pas mais il a dans
l'esprit de vous livrer un véhicule
entier c'est exactement la même chose
sur ce type de prestation aujourd'hui ça
s'anticipe et le fart force est de
constater qu'il ya eu défaut
d'anticipation
alors vous parliez de ce double scrutin
de cette organisation d'élections
régionales et également des élections
départementales est ce que c'est l'une
des explications de cette défaillance il
ya eu un échange assez musclé entre
philippe by mr l'inter gérald darmanin
on va d'abord regarder cet échange et
puis après on ira voir philippe bas
contrairement à ce que vous avez dit en
2008 il y a eu un scrutin cantonal et un
scrutin municipal en même temps aucune
difficulté de type de celle que nous
constatons cette année enfin monsieur
bah pardon de vous dire que vous dit une
bêtise 2008 n'a pas été une année le
double scrutin
elle a été une année de scrutin
municipal et pour la moitié
en ce scrutin cantonal pour la première
fois mais qui dit une bêtise monsieur le
ministre je sais bien vous monsieur le
bas si vous me le permettez
et justement on va retrouver le sénateur
les républicains philippe bas qui est en
salle des conférences du sénat avec vous
quand un calme est tout à fait alex
bonjour philippe bazin l ère de la
manche un petit thé change un peu
musclée ce matin des échanges
d'amabilités avec gérald darmanin qu'est
ce que vous avez pensé de cette audition
qui avait lieu au sénat est ce que le
ministre de l'intérieur a pu répondre à
toutes vos interrogations ce matin non
le ministre de l'intérieur a répondu à
côté des questions qui lui étaient
posées
il a invoqué la responsabilité de
monsieur jospin il ya 20 ans le fait que
les listes électorales ne comportait pas
toujours les bonnes adresses je signale
que depuis 2019 ce gouvernement a mis en
oeuvre une réforme pour les fiabiliser
et il a indiqué qu' une partie de la
difficulté venait du fait qu'il y avait
deux élections en même temps ce qui
selon le ministre ne se serait pas
produit depuis 1986 je lui ai juste fait
remarquer qu' il y avait eu aussi des
élections cantonales et des élections
municipales en même temps en 2008 et que
depuis 20 ans que la concurrence
s'exerce et existent sur le service
postal
nous n'avons jamais eu de trouble de
cette ampleur qui ont tout de même
privés d'informations des millions
d'électeurs qui ont l'habitude de lire
toutes les professions de foi et de
préparer d'ailleurs leur bulletin de
vote à la maison et je crois que pour
avoir entendu et moi même tenu mon
bureau de vote dimanche dernier vraiment
avoir entendu beaucoup de concitoyens
la non distribution des professions de
foi est quelque chose qui dans
l'histoire de la république ne s'est
jamais vu la responsabilité pour le bon
exercice de la démocratie du ministre de
l'intérieur est pleinement engagée et
nous attendons autre chose que d'imputer
la responsabilité à d'autres que lui
même monsieur bah la commission des lois
va être dotée
demain des compétences d'une commission
d' enquête afin de faire la lumière sur
ces dysfonctionnements le problème at il
pu impacter la sincérité du scrutin
c'est la question que tout le monde se
pose et qu'est-ce que quelle sera la
suite est ce que ça pourrait être
invalidée par un tribunal si c'était le
cas qu'est ce que vous en pensez
non il faut pas rentrer dans cette
démarche car il n'y a pas de candidats
qui ont été favorisés par rapport à
d'autres il n'y a pas eu deux manoeuvres
de nature à altérer la sincérité du
scrutin et le conseil d'état s'est déjà
prononcée dans des affaires de beaucoup
moindre importance sur les conséquences
qu'il accepte de tirer d'un désordre de
ce type alors il s'est prononcé sur un
désordre en miniature par rapport à ce
qui existe déjà mais les principes sont
les mêmes noms la question n'est pas une
question sur la sincérité du scrutin
c'est une question sur la responsabilité
gouvernementale d'organiser des
élections en assurant l'égalité des
candidats et la correcte informations de
nos concitoyens un dernier mot philippe
bas quelles sont les suites après cette
commission denquête est ce que le
législateur devra revenir par exemple et
bien sûr cette délégation de service
public qui a été proposé notamment
lionel jospin on s'en souvient est-ce
qu'il faut revenir sur la mesure je le
crois mais hilare à retenir du
gouvernement vous savez gouverner c'est
prévoir
comme disait mendès france il
appartenait au gouvernement de le faire
et de ne pas attendre la catastrophe
démocratique que nous avons connue pour
le proposer
et puis par ailleurs le cahier des
charges de l'appel d'offres aurait
mérité certainement d'être mieux conçu
plus précis pour que les obligations
soient plus fortes et que le contrôle
exercé dans les semaines qui précèdent
le scrutin par l'état soit également
plus rigoureux on peut pas simplement
évacuer sa responsabilité en disant on
va maintenant changer la loi il aurait
fallu la changer avant bien merci mais
ainsi philippe bas ce matin l ère de la
manche d'avoir répondu merci direct à
nos questions et on sera bien sûr les
travaux de la commission des lois
devenues demain la commission d' enquête
sur le sujet
alex merci beaucoup
enfin ludovic est une question très
simple est ce que le gouvernement a une
responsabilité dans cet échec de la
distribution des problèmes des
professions de foi
encore une fois je pense que la lumière
sera faite après le second tour
aujourd'hui je suis désolé quand on
demande à une entreprise de faire
quelque chose il faut aussi qu'elle soit
en mesure de le faire je jeu et sa
tranche quand même avec le
professionnalisme et je tiens à le
souligner aussi des mères dont certains
des maires et des élus des agents
territoriaux contenu des bureaux de vote
alors que la veille au soir il était
saoul et cru voir le matin même pour
certaines communes je veux dire il ya un
moment il ya des personnes
il ya des entreprises qui doivent
travailler avant les élections c'était
le cas de ces entreprises de
distribution et à celles qui travaillent
le jour j aucune commune à part quelques
détails à marseille mais aucune commune
n'a failli dans la tenue des bureaux de
vote
et dieu sait s'il y avait aussi des bons
nombre de conditions qui auraient permis
de ne pas retenir donc aujourd'hui
chacun doit tenir doit doit respecter
son engagement et pour moi l'état
respecté son engagement même si encore
une fois ya des choses perfectibles
sophie tripoli moi je voudrais dire deux
choses d'abord évidemment il faut aussi
mesurer les conséquences de cette
nouvelle organisation des élections sur
les candidats et candidates qui avaient
des délais beaucoup plus serré pour
rendre leurs documents et qui eux ont
tenu les délais deuxièmement bien sûr
c'est la responsabilité du gouvernement
c'est la responsabilité du pouvoir
exécutif que de s'assurer que les choses
vont bien se dérouler et singulièrement
des élections c'est la base d'une
démocratie
donc évidemment cette question elle est
majeure et le gouvernement doit vraiment
se poser les questions et les résoudre à
l'avenir et proposer des solutions
moi je crois au service public et je
pense que quand la poste était un
service public avec des agents avec des
statuts solide et bien les choses ne se
posait pas de la même manière après pour
terminer quand même bien entendu je
crois que tous et toutes nous devons
être extrêmement préoccupés par la
question de l'abstention qui évidemment
ne peut être exclusivement expliqué par
cette question là mais cette question
reste quand même majeurs mais
effectivement abstention euros
or pour ce premier tour des élections
régionales 66,1 % et gérard larcher le
président du sénat est très critique il
parle de fragilité démocratique de la
période
regardez ce que lui a répondu il y à
quelques minutes le porte parole du
gouvernement
gabriella talent je m'étonne
régulièrement d'entendre certains
responsables politiques regretté des
fragilités que nous connaissons dans
notre démocratie qui ne sont pas
nouvelles c'était déjà un constat qui a
été fait au moment de la campagne
présidentielle de 2017
mais quand j'entends monsieur larcher je
me dis finalement monsieur larcher est
assis dans son siège de sénateur depuis
avant ma naissance
il a occupé des fonctions de sénateur
pendant des décennies il a été ministre
il semble aujourd'hui amputée des phares
la fragilité qu'on constate dans notre
démocratie à ce gouvernement sans se
poser une seule seconde la question de
la responsabilité qu'il a pu avoir avec
d'autres et d'autres responsables
politiques par le passé jean raymond
legault n'est ça vous fait bondir ses
propos de gabrielat talent et bien
longtemps qu'on va pas bondir quand on
entend des inepties
mais entendre le ministre de l'intérieur
qui vient ce matin dire à monsieur
philippe bas auxquels j'adresse toutes
mes amitiés dire qu'il dit des bêtises
il va le regretter cette parole je vous
le dis je vous le dis quant à monsieur
attal sincèrement qui le prend encore au
sérieux qui le prend en cause quand il
aura fait dans sa vie politique
le car si dieu lui prête vie le quart de
ce café gérard larcher de son sens de la
responsabilité de l'état plutôt que
d'être devant ddd des caméras dès qu'on
entend une si vous voulez il faut être
un peu sérieux la réalité des choses
c'est que ce pouvoir est arrogant ce
gouvernement est incapable d'organiser
la démocratie je le dis avec force la
démocratie ça passe par des élections
le pouvoir est en pleine déliquescence
le résultat des scrutins
attendons le second tour mais il indique
clairement des choses c'est que la
république en marche est un concept
fumeux et que ces gens ces gens qui
viennent nous donner des leçons tous les
quatre matins de fret devrait faire
preuve de beaucoup d'humilité et de
regarder devant leur porte parce que le
nouveau monde
croyez moi il est pas beau ludovic est
ce que vous pensez de ces critiques du
porte en lui
- en réponse à gérard larcher écoutez
moi je suis plutôt un adepte de la
construction on peut récupérer
politiquement savoir si c'est la faute
du gouvernement ou pas on peut
s'offusquer effectivement d'une parole
que qui peut qui peut être malheureuse
moi j'ai envie de penser à nos électeurs
et de dire voilà aujourd'hui pourquoi il
ya une telle abstention
qu'est ce qu'on leur propose quand on
dit qu'il ya choc des générations les
anciens prépare les anciennes
générations préparent leur voix de chez
elle et peuvent avoir été impacté les
nouvelles générations elle regarde
plutôt sur les sites internet ce qui se
passent elles n'ont pas été impactées et
pourtant ne sont pas venus voter
donc il ya d'autres sujets effectivement
on peut en débattre très longtemps ici
savoir ce qu a dit un autre
encore une fois monsieur la construction
qu'est ce qu'on propose à l'avenir
qu'est ce qu'on propose à la fois pour
que ces fiascos n'apparaissent pas
n'apparaissent plus et puis surtout
qu'est ce qu'on propose comme à l'heure
où on parle du vote électronique est ce
qu'on est ce qu on part sur c'est sur
ces dossiers là rapidement sofitel
polluants pour conclure oui deux choses
d'abord je crois que la question que
nous devons nous poser c'est que la
république notre vème république et ses
institutions sont à bout de souffle et
je pense que c'est pas des questions de
savoir si on vote avec un papier en
appuyant sur un bouton
la vraie question la vraie question
c'est la question nos institutions et de
la place des citoyens et des citoyennes
dans la prise de décision ça c'est
majeur est vraiment c'est ce qu'il faut
ce à quoi il faut travailler à l'avenir
ce sera le mot de la fin merci beaucoup
à tous les soirs d'avoir été mes invités
sur ce plateau nous sommes maintenant à
30 minutes du début des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement toute notre
équipe est en place quand un calme est
en salle des conférences jean m'assieds
sur twitch et jérôme rabier dans la
tribune de presse de l'hémicycle du
sénat ingérons quelles vont être les
thèmes forts de cette séance de
questions d'actualité a dans cet entre
deux tours des élections régionales et
départementales vous venez d'en parler
on va beaucoup parler de ces élections
une question autour du niveau
l'abstention qui a marqué le premier
tour plusieurs questions sur les
dysfonctionnements dans la livraison des
professions de foi un sujet qui fait
l'actualité du sénat après l'audition ce
matin de gérald darmanin par les
sénateurs de la commission des lois et
après la décision du bureau du sénat
aujourd'hui de créer une mission
d'information avec les pouvoirs d'une
commission d' enquête sur ce sujet on
aura aussi une question sur la nécessité
ou non du front républicain au second
tour en venant les autres sujets abordés
y aura deux questions sur l'allocation
adulte handicapé vous le savez le sénat
avait voté la déconvenue gallisa sion de
cette allocation mais la semaine
dernière les députés de la majorité ont
rejeté à la mesure ça fait hurler un les
oppositions il y aura aujourd'hui une
question du groupe socialiste est une
question du groupe l'est républicain sur
ce sujet polémique
on évoquera aussi les autres sujets
sains qui font l'actualité comme les
intérêts les intempéries qui ont frappé
notamment les hôtes france la suspension
par le conseil d'état de la réforme de
l'assurance chômage ou enfin
l'encadrement des événements festifs
après notamment les débordements et les
évacuations policière lors de la fête de
la musique dans plusieurs villes de
france ce lundi cette question ça sera
la première question elle sera posée par
le sénateur écologiste du rhône
thomas dessus merci beaucoup jérôme pour
ce point complet on va maintenant parler
du projet de loi climat qui a examiné en
ce moment au sénat est une mesure fait
beaucoup parler la fermeture des lignes
aériennes intérieures quand il existe
une alternative en train en moins de
2h30 c'est l'objet de notre face à face
entre d'un côté le sénateur écologiste
de loire-atlantique ronan dantec bonjour
et de l'autre le sénateur de la vienne
rattaché au groupe l'est républicain du
sénat bruno belin bonjour bonjour alors
avant d'ouvrir le débat sur cette
fermeture de certaines lignes aériennes
on va voir le contenu de l'âme
mesures du projet de loi les
explications de jordan quand il pourrait
y avoir trois disons aérienne en moins
en métropole si l'article 36 du projet
de loi climat que les sénateurs
examinent et définitivement adoptée
terminées les paris nantes paris lyon
paris bordeaux il faudra alors utiliser
le train car la proposition est clair si
une alternative ferroviaire en moins de
2h30 et sans changement existent il
faudra alors suspendre la liaison par
avion objectif réduire les émissions de
co2 mais pour certains sénateurs
socialistes ça ne va pas assez loin
le sénat a voté dès le début du texte
une trajectoire de réduction de 55 % des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre à
l'horizon 2030 si on reste sur une
limitation des vols du transport aérien
intérieur sur l'alternative 2h30
la réduction sera de moins de 10% et
donc c'est totalement incohérent avec la
position générale d'autres sénateurs ne
l'entendent pas de cette oreille ils
sont plusieurs à avoir signé une tribune
intitulée we à l'aviation
ils défendent un secteur qui distille
c'est totalement impliqué dans le green
deal
cyril belva est l'un des cosignataires
de la tribune l'impact global sur
l'effet de serre du secteur aérien c'est
à 2 2 5%
donc finalement je pense que c'est peut
être un peu tôt effectivement d'avoir
une mesure comme celle ci sachant qu'en
plus haut niveau de l'union européenne
on sait pas dans quelle mesure elle
pourra être transmet table ou en tout
cas cohérente
cet article émane directement de la
proposition faite par la convention
citoyenne sur le climat leur idée était
de supprimer les liaisons aériennes
lorsqu une alternative en train de moins
de quatre heures existe un tel scénario
suspendrait alors 23 vols internes
voilà pour ce sujet de jordan klein
ronan dantec un mot sur le principe de
cette mesure
fermer certaines lignes aériennes quand
il existe une alternative en train avec
une durée à peu près équivalente à une
heure près c'est du bon sens écologique
c'est du bon sens et c'est un symbole
mais c'est une question assez secondaire
au final
il faut savoir et les sucres de cire une
pelle va s'en faut le transport est
aujourd'hui en france avec l'ensemble
des forces s'agira d'actifs s'était pas
juste les émissions directes de co2 par
le kérosène mais c'est aussi les nuages
qui sont créés c'est plutôt le doubs
donc c'est 5% on veut réduire c'est ce
que vous avez nous avons tous voté dans
la loi
nos émissions à -55% en 2030 dans dix
ans donc ça veut dire qu'en fait quand
on fait le calcul
dans dix ans il transport aérien
continue de se développer c'est entre 10
et 15% des émissions au niveau national
et avec l'explosion du trafic aérien au
niveau mondial certains chiffres assez
sérieux 10 c'est plus propre
pratiquement peut-être 20 25 % des
émissions mondiales liées au transport
et donc on ne peut pas continuer comme
ça ce matin rapport du giec rappelle le
giec c'est la communauté scientifique
internationale sous l'égide de l'onu qui
disent si on n'agit pas massivement dans
les dix ans nos sociétés s'effondre
c'est pas des c'est pas des choses
secondaires ses terres nos sociétés à
l'échelle 1 mondial ne tiendront pas un
réchauffement aussi important qui va
jeter sur les routes des centaines de
millions de personnes et remettre en
cause l'autonomie alimentaire mondial
donc c'est une mesure assez symbolique
que nous défendons nous re déposeront un
amendement pour trois heures et demie
mais plus important c'est de faire en
sorte
et là philippe tabarot le rapporteur
républicains étaient très clairs là
dessus et je le rejoins l'important
surtout c'est que le transport aérien
soit aux vrais coups et si léo vrai coup
il y aura un report massif vers le rail
un développement du transport
ferroviaire et donc c'est plutôt autour
des coûts du transport aérien que sont
nos principaux amendements grenoble en
face à cette urgence climatique qui
gronde et ce qu'il faut prendre des
mesures pour toucher secteur aérien
alors de quoi parle-t-on cela on est
parti un peu partout avec ma collègue on
est
j'aurais aimé qu'ils nous parlent de la
loire atlantique et de nantes atlantique
notamment de quoi parle t-on
d'aménagement territoire et de lignes
intérieures à prendre un exemple quand
même comme ça à éviter de se noyer dans
les chiffres ou les rapports un exemple
paris bordeaux on veut supprimer le
paris bordeaux paris mérignac sous
prétexte qu'il ya les légers v
aujourd'hui toute l'activité de l'ouest
de la métropole bordelaise se fait à
mérignac et se faisait ou se fait parce
que justement il ya ces vols on supprime
ces vols on va profiter de la gare
saint-jean qui est en plein centre de
bordeaux dans le maire écologiste on a
juste qu'il en fait de la ville plein
centre de bordeaux ou pour rejoindre la
plateforme économique qui est à l'ouest
de bordeaux on leur met des véhicules
l'ensemble des bandeaux moi je le prends
souvent bordeaux et vous comprenez vous
étiez pas claire mais parce que vous me
laissez pas terminé mais sur l'exemple
de bordeaux
on voit bien que ça rajoute de la
voiture j'y vais régulièrement et on
pourrait reprendre l'exemple de nantes
avec nantes atlantique un 2è règle aucun
problème nous répondu à aucune question
prenons des exemples concrets qui
parlent à notre territoire les lignes
intérieures sont utiles on le voit sur
les transports de greffe sur les
transports sur l'économie sur
l'aménagement du territoire sur des
lignes intérieures sur des au respect
voilà de quoi parle-t-on très
précisément dans cet article on peut
globalement sur les 35 36 et 38 on est
en train de vouloir dézinguer l'aviation
alors que c'est un fleuron de l'économie
française qui est utile
on a bien vu les progrès qu'elle a
permis pas si on en était resté à
l'aviation l'art nautique d'avant guerre
on serait pas aujourd'hui dans l'ère du
numérique pendant que soutenons ce kit
est utile à la population belin dans
votre réponse vous n'avez pas parlé d'
effet de serre vous croyez à l'effet de
serre vous croyez à la gravité de cette
crise climatique
ne culpabilisez pas les gens répondaient
à ma question vous croyez la gravité de
cette crise climatique nous culpabiliser
croyez au rallye du chèque
vous croyez au rapport du giec nu de ce
matin ne culpabilisez pas une question
simple vous croyez au plus gros budget
quand vous me laisserez parler je
pourrais vous faites à la fois le
professeur est celui qui donne les
extrêmement sain voilà alors personne
n'est insensible à ce qui se passe sauf
que il faut savoir quels sont les bons
leviers
vous parlez du ferroviaire quid des
régions et dans certaines régions je
pourrai reprendre l'exemple de nouvelles
qui tiennent
où en sont l'état des lignes
ferroviaires si vous voulez faire
poitiers limoges vous avez du mal
aujourd'hui
donc la question n'est pas de remettre
en cause ce qui pourrait être une
évidence une question c'est quelles sont
les bons leviers et est-ce que supprimer
les neuf paris-bordeaux change 0,0001 %
du sujet quid des vols venant de l'asie
du sud-est quid des vols transpacifiques
femme à la regardons ce qui est utile
performant intelligent or vous n'êtes
pas dans l'intelligence territoriale en
faisant ça donc on attaque juste une
question je me barre me poser une
question est ce que c'est un peu enclavé
est ce que ça peu enclavé certains
territoires de fermer certaines lignes
intérieures
nous avons proposé trois heures trente
pour les aéroports qui ne sont pas
connectés par tgv avec le fait justement
d'avoir une sécurité de lignes
ferroviaires
personne ne prend l'avion pour
économiser sur trois heures trente
parce que de centre-ville à centre-ville
3h30 c'est moins coûteux en temps que
d'aller jusqu'à marignane pour prendre
marseille paris et se retrouver à orly
ou roissy redescendre sur le son de
paris la seule raison pour laquelle on
prend encore l'avion sur des voyages de
moins 3 heures 30 c'est parce qu'il est
moins cher et parce qu'il y à du dumping
tva à 10%
aucune taxation du kérosène voir des
financements régionaux sur un salon de
l'aéroport nous on voudrait juste que le
transport aérien soit aux vrais coups et
je reconnais que le rapporteur tabarot
notamment en sécurisant la taxe chirac
et qu'elles ne soient pas remises en
cause sur ses skis et patience et mai
je parle de la taqiyya que les pas sur
ces vols la dont on vient de parler et
surtout les boys mais c'est surtout les
vols connaissaient un peu votre dossier
sur tous les vols mais simplement êtes
vous d'accord pour que le transport
aérien soit au vrai coup et vous n'avez
toujours pas répondu à ma question quels
sont vos mesures si vous considérez
qu'il faut tenir le moins 55 % en 2030
pour réduire les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre à ce niveau là je les
attends toujours une violence qu'il faut
augmenter le coût de l'avion après sa
longue durée avec le trans est un enjeu
pour les collectivités parce qu'on sait
bien que sur certaines lignes
intérieures ou sur certaines lignes
proches les collectivités abondent
sauf que si elles le font c'est qu'elle
estime en toute bonne libre
administration qui reste quand même un
point de vue constitutionnel que ça peut
rapporter à l'économie de leur
territoire on a aussi des questions
d'emploi sur l'aviation
il ya tout ça qu'il faut mettre
évidemment dans la balance on ne nie pas
les sujets planétaire climatique quand
même il faut permet pas fait preuve de
deux dans le débat des couteaux si donc
il n'y a pas cette négation mais il y a
effectivement d'autres enjeux le secteur
aéronautique a fait d'énormes progrès on
l'a encore vu récemment avec un vol vers
montréal où 30 à 40% d'économie on le
voit aujourd'hui ce que si vous voulez
des chiffons pour donner oui je connais
mon dossier
on est à 2 litres aux 100 kilomètres par
passager sur des lignes intérieures
donc voilà il ya eu une évolution de
l'aéronautique
c'est un secteur utile et donc il faut
le soutenir et le débat sera sans doute
animé cette semaine au sénat sur cette
mesure et sur toutes les mesures qui
concerne l'avion dans ce projet de loi
climat ces jeux clos à ce face à face je
vous libère bruno belin vous rester avec
moi ronan dantec ce qu'on va commenter
plusieurs sujets d'actualité
je vous libère bruno balent ce que je
crois vous allez voir dans quelques
instants thoniers estanguet le patron de
l'organisation des jeux olympiques et
paralympiques 2020 2024 qui est au sénat
aujourd'hui pour la journée
international olympique
et justement on va aller en salle des
conférences du sénat puisque tony
estanguet tu avec quentin calmet et il
ya également le sénateur de l'isère
michel savin qui est un des spécialistes
au sénat des questions sportives est
exactement alex aujourd'hui nous sommes
le 20
3 juin journée est bien de l'olympisme
et du paralympiques mme en france
l'occasion d'une visite de tony
estanguet
bonjour messieurs bonjour monsieur ça va
effectivement sénateur a l'air de
l'isère et spécialiste des questions de
sport ici au sénat un mot sur cette
visite aujourd'hui on savait conférence
c'était quoi l'occasion de cette visite
bonjour a tous écouté c'est un plaisir
effectivement pour parrainer 1024 de
venir au sénat le sénat a souhaité
symboliser son soutien aux athlètes des
équipes de france qui vont aller à tokyo
dans un mois pile jour pour jour pour
représenter la france et je trouve que
c'est chouette que ces athlètes qui
viennent de tous les territoires soient
soutenus par le sénat 1-2 olympique à
tokyo s'en fait ça va être un peu des
jeux olympiques un peu spéciaux cette
année les annonces ce matin
l'organisation des jeux pas
d'embrassades pas d'autographe ça va
être un peu oui quand même des jeux avec
des spectateurs c'est aussi un très beau
signal quand sortie de cette crise on
soit de nouveau capable d'organiser
cette grande fête internationale qui va
accueillir plus de 200 pays dans
quelques semaines estanguet un petit mot
d'actualité on a vu que munich voulait
éclairer son stade aux couleurs de la
communauté lgbt
suite à ces loi hongroise contre les
lgbt finalement lui fassiez opposé
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous
moi je pense qu'il faut garder une forme
de neutralité de ces grands événements
sportifs sinon on va se retrouver avec
des prises de paroles de sujets de
société sur chacun des événements
aujourd'hui la popularité et l'attrait
de ces grands événements sportifs c'est
d'abord parce que on retrouve des
moments des moments d'émotion et ça je
pense qu'il faut qu'on le protège qu'on
le préserve ça ne veut pas dire qu'en
marge des grands événements on ne soit
pas plus exemplaires sur le respect des
droits des athlètes et des spectateurs
et c'est effectivement on a aussi un
rôle à jouer en matière d'exemplarité
un mot un dernier mot avec vous avant de
poser quelques questions à monsieur sa
main mais où en est-on de l'organisation
de ces jeux en 2024 en france est-ce que
tout va bien malgré la crise sanitaire
dans 45 jours on se prépare à prendre le
relais après les autos qu à l'occasion
de la cérémonie clôture et on est prêt
pour ce moment ce très symbolique
cent ans après les derniers jours
les jeux dans notre pays et on vous
prépare trois années de folie où on va
vraiment développer la place du sport
partout dans notre pays on a envie de
faire rêver cette génération 2024 et de
démontrer combien cet événement est un
horizon très fort d'un point de vue
économique d'un point de vue sportif et
d'un point de vue social monsieur savin
le sénat chambre des territoires est ce
que ces jeux vont dépasser la petite
couronne de paris et pouvoir s'inscrire
dans une logique vraiment de tout le
pays
c'est l'objectif de paris 2024 1 et
c'est pour ça aussi que le sénat ait
vraiment partenaires de parler de 1024
dans l'opération terre de jeu qui
s'adresse directement aux collectivités
de la plus petite commune de petits
petits villages jusqu'aux grandes cités
urbaines les départements les régions
doivent se mobiliser
ça a commencé c'est bien parti et je
crois que c'est l'objectif l'héritage
numéro 1 de paris de lille 24 c est que
les français pratiquent plus d'activités
physiques et sportives
le président larcher qui doit s'exprimer
en ouverture de cette séance des
questions à propos justement des jeux
olympiques c'est quoi le message
exactement le message c'est ce que vous
a dit tout à l'heure tony estanguet
c'est que de démontrer que le présent du
sénat mais l'ensemble des sénateurs
toutes sensibilités confondues est
derrière l'équipe de france olympique et
paralympique à l'ouverture un mois des
jo de tokyo est aussi ça signale aussi
d'un courage mans dans la préparation de
parts et 2024 parce qu'on sait l'équipe
de tennis quand estanguet fin et londres
travaillent dans la préparation et des
collectivités sont prêtes aussi à
soutenir ce projet un dernier mot pour
vous tony estanguet
qu'est ce que c'est très important c'est
très fort les athlètes ont besoin de
soutien ils sortent de deux saisons
compliquées à cause de la crise due
qu'au guide ils n'auront pas leurs
supporters pour la première fois aux
jeux de tokyo
c'est important que toute la france
poussent derrière ces athlètes ces
champions qui vont aller chercher des
médailles pour pour la france et c'est
vrai quel beau message que le sénat
aujourd'hui soit en soutien de cette
équipe de france olympique et
paralympique et des badges ont été
distribués à tous les sénateurs en fait
qu'effectivement le logo
des jeux olympiques merci d'avoir fait
l'amitié public c'est de venir sur cette
antenne aaron diffusera pas forcément
beaucoup d'épreuves sur notre antenne on
sera quand même ça de très près je vous
le promets merci à vous tous merci
beaucoup quentin pour cette interview en
direct de la salle des conférences
remontait qu'un mot sur ces jeux
olympiques paris 2024 c'est une bonne
nouvelle ça peut relancer le pays après
toute cette crise je sais pas si ça
relance le pays mais moi ya certains
territoires qu'il faut garder l'utopie
des jeux olympiques depuis leur création
par part de coubertin avec un message
qui était quand même un message
extrêmement pacifiste dans l'idée de de
coubertin
même s'il n'était pas encore très
égalitariste il écrira un livre qui
raconte l'histoire du sport une
quinzaine d'années donc il n'était pas
progresser surtout pierre de coubertin
mais malgré tout c'est une utopie est en
fait c'est une utopie assez proche de
l'utopie climatique
aujourd'hui c'est à dire le climat c'est
tout le monde ensemble qui fait sa part
de l'effort qui prend sa part de
responsabilité ce que n'a pas fait notre
collègue tout à l'heure c'était on est
dans ce moment où soit nous nous
replions sur nous mêmes
on essaye finalement de résister à des
crises qui s'annonce
soit on est dans une utopie fraternel à
l'échelle planétaire où justement aussi
si je fais ma part l'autre fera plus
facilement sa part et c'est toute la
dynamique des négociations de l'accord
de paris donc des jeux olympiques
finalement nourri cet imaginaire après
il faut le nourrir de manière
responsable c'est à dire que tout ce qui
est fait réduit l'empreinte carbone et
ce qui ne peut pas être réduits parce
que là il y aura des avions là ça veut
dire aussi une compensation financière
extrêmement forte
un des grands enjeux de l'aviation c'est
quand même le prix de la compensation
qui doit être extrêmement élevé on
sentait qu'on va retrouver notre
streamer politique jean nassiet qui va
commenter cette séance de questions
d'actualité sur la plateforme switch
avec toute sa communauté
jean quelles sont les attentes de ta
communauté sur cette séance écoute
alexandre ya plusieurs sujets qui
intéressent les internautes le premier
et tu t'en doutes c'est le taux
d'abstention très important de la
semaine dernière il aimerait bien savoir
si le gouvernement al'intention de la
portée des réformes des changements pour
les modes de vote
on parle beaucoup du vote électronique
du vote par correspondance de la prise
en compte du vote blanc
ces départs ressorte à l'occasion de
cette élection régionale donc à voir si
les sénateurs et sénatrices poseront ces
questions
cet aprèm
un autre sujet qui intéresse beaucoup
les internautes c'est la suite
en fait la suite après ces élections
régionales qu'est ce qu'il fasse passer
va-t-il y avoir un remaniement est ce
que le gouvernement a l'intention de
maintenir son rythme de réformes on sait
qu emmanuelle bach
on y tient pas tant à voir un retour de
la réforme des retraites si oui dans
quel calendrier
pareil pour la loi la loi territoriale
la loi cadre des on dit yu voilà un peu
des questions sur comment va se passer
la dernière année du quinquennat
d'emmanuel macro on aimerait bien avoir
des éclaircissements à paris en novembre
et le dernier sujet qui intéresse les
internautes cet après midi c'est ce
fameux pré-rapport fiac qui est sorti
qui se veut très alarmiste sur la
situation climatique est ce que le
gouvernement estime que nous sommes à la
hauteur des attentes d'un point de vue
de la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique voilà alex des trois sujets
qui intéressent beaucoup les internautes
aujourd'hui
mais justement ronan dantec en parler en
plateau de ce rapport alarmant des
experts internationaux du giec sur le
climat direction maintenant à la salle
des conférences du sénat où quentin
calmet est avec le président du groupe
centriste au sénat hervé marseille
oui tout à fait alex chez avec un seuil
bonjour monsieur le président un mot
d'abord sur ce torchon qui brûle entre
le président du sénat et le porte parole
du gouvernement
je réexplique un petit peu pour nos
téléspectateurs mais ce matin le
président du sénat gérard larcher a dit
qu'à force de vouloir faire du en même
temps ni gauche ni droite et bien
emmanuel macron avait fragmenter la
démocratie ce à quoi
gabriel attal a répondu en sortie du
conseil des ministres il a dit que
gérard marché était dans son fauteuil de
sénateur
avant sa naissance et quand quelques
sorties il n'avait pas fait grand chose
non plus pour revigorer la démocratie
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette passe
d'armes entre le porte parole du
gouvernement et qu'un du sénat
aujourd'hui
écoutez je pense que le président du
sénat
à raison de dire que le président de la
république a un peu j'allais dire lancé
des bombes à fragmentation qui ont
j'ai à lui dire détruit beaucoup
d'institutions dans ce pays le
gouvernement le parlement les partis il
ya plus beaucoup de références et ça
fait partie j'allais dire des
manquements qui contribue à l'abstention
parce que dans un pays où il ya plus de
référencement il faut pas s'étonner que
le crédit de la parole publique n'existe
plus et qu'à partir de là les gens
restent chez eux
un mot sur et bien votre commission des
lois à laquelle vous appartenez qui dès
demain devrait prendre les fonctions de
reprendre les êtres les traits d'une
commission d' enquête sur les
dysfonctionnements dans la livraison de
la propagande électorale
quelle est l'idée avec cette nouvelle
commission denquête qui démarre demain
écoutez toutes les formations politiques
tous les groupes représentés au sénat
ont constaté à travers leurs membres que
les opérations électorales avaient été
marquées par beaucoup de difficultés il
a manqué des documents ils ont été mal
diffusée sans arriver en retard
c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas
admissible dans un pays comme le nôtre
donc il faut aller rechercher les
responsabilités savoir ce qui s'est
passé parce qu'il va y avoir d'autres
élections
singulièrement la présidentielle ce sont
les mêmes entreprises qui vont
travailler pour la présidentielle et
donc il faut savoir ce qui va se passer
éventuellement changer modifier et
réformer la législation pour faire en
sorte que ça se passe bien un dernier
mot monsieur marseille le gouvernement
veut lancer une campagne de
communication est clair sur les réseaux
sociaux pour inciter à voter dimanche
notamment les jeunes qui se sont
beaucoup abstenus que peut-on faire pour
dimanche prochain où est-ce que c'est
déjà trop tard
je crains malheureusement et j'espère me
tromper que
ce ne soit trop tard encore une fois les
gens qui ne votent pas ne vois tu pas
parce que il ne croit plus en la parole
publique qui pensent que voter ça va
rien changer pour eux donc pour redonner
du crédit à la parole publique et je
pense que le président serait bien
inspiré en évitant de lancer des débats
qui n'ont pas de suite comme la réforme
de la constitution comme la sécurité le
terrorisme etc
merci avait main saillants sur a et
travaux de cette commission enquête qui
doit rendre un rapport d'ici juillet
merci à marseille merci beaucoup
quentin ronan dantec un mot sur cette
abstention je voudrais juste rappeler
qu'au début du quinquennat d'emmanuel
macro et bien françois bayrou a mené le
projet loi pour plus de confiance dans
la vie politique dans la vie
démocratique
est ce que cette abstention au premier
tour des élections régionales s'est un
peu l'échec des manuels macron moi je
crois que notre théâtre politique
n'intéresse plus les français
n'obtiennent politique c'est nous les
acteurs plus ou moins bon vous qui ont
qualifié et qui avait aussi tendance à
choisir les acteurs donc ce qui amène
derrière une espèce de dynamique
mortifère entre nous et que ça
n'intéresse plus les français on parle
du giec qui dit nos sociétés ne vont pas
survivre
c'est ça que les jeunes entendent
aujourd'hui
moi j'ai autour de moi plein de jeunes
qui me disent c'est terrible je ne ferai
pas d'enfant je ne ferai pas d'enfant
donc la discussion entre nous qui
devrait mobiliser tous nos temps
d'antenne la question que j'ai posée à
mon collègue belin sait lire bon c'est
quoi les propositions de la droite pour
faire moins 55 % d'émissions de gaz à
effet de serre en 2030
parce que si la france ne fait pas moins
55% nous serons pas en situation de
demander aux américains et aux chinois
aux indiens de faire leur part de
l'effort il n'a pas répondu
il n'a pas répondu il était en défense
de l'aviation d'autres sont défense de
la distribution des dépliants
publicitaires d'autres sombres en
défense de la vaisselle jetable et ainsi
de suite
cette fragmentation là n'est pas à
l'échelle moi ce que je veux du débat
politique
je veux que la droite républicaine me
dise pour atteindre et moi 55% nous on
fera comme ça avec une approche libérale
moi je le ferai de manière plus polie
cicatrices et on débat le peuple tranche
mais nous n'avons pas ce débat là
et les propos d' attal ou d'autres
propos participe finalement toujours lem
démobilisation il est temps qu'on se
ressaisisse et qu'on se remette en cause
sur le fait que notre théâtre
n'intéresse plus les français ronan
dantec on va retourner en salle des
conférences du sénat alors qu'on voit l
arrivée du premier ministre jean castex
pour cette séance de questions
d'actualité et au micro de quentin calme
et il ya le président de la commission
des lois du sénat françois noël buffet
voilà tout à fait alex le présent la
commission des lois qui donc dès demain
bonjour monsieur buffet devant le
président d'une commission denquête
puisque la commission des lois va être
dotée des prérogatives d'une commission
denquête quelle est l'idée monsieur
buffet et quel est le spectre exactement
que vous allez explorer avec cette
commission mais l'idée c'est qu'en ayant
les pouvoirs d'une commission denquête
on peut se faire communiquer toutes les
pièces utiles auditionné toute personne
que nous souhaitons sincèrement donc
d'une même c'était un pouvoir renforcé
quel est l'objectif savoir et comprendre
pourquoi le système de distribution de
la propagande électorale a totalement
dysfonctionné et qu'il constitue de ce
fait une forme de fiasco
de surcroît ne jurera janyk il ya un
enjeu qui est l'enjeu du prochain
scrutin s'était de dimanche prochain
aussi une abstention record avec ces
élections dimanche dernier on parle
d'une abstention de 66 72 %
le premier est plus large que la simple
distribution des propagandes n'est ce
pas bien sûr mais vous avez raison
si ce n'était que ces problèmes là ce
serait pas grave mais malheureusement
l'abstention c'est aussi une défiance à
l'égard de la politique et moi ce que je
voudrais c'est qu'on tienne compte de
cela en considérant qu' arrêter les
petites phrases arrêter de tirer le
débat vers le bas
au contraire donne en la prenant de la
hauteur de nom de la hauteur mobilisons
nos concitoyens sur des grands projets
sur un destin collectif
mais arrêtons ce qui se passait jusqu'à
maintenant qui est mortifère pour la
démocratie on le voit depuis ce matin on
voit une passe d'armes entre le
président du sénat gérard larcher et
gabriel atta le porte parole du
gouvernement
en sortie du conseil des ministres le
porte parole du mouvement a dit que j'ai
un marché était dans son fauteuil de
sénateur
bien avant sa naissance etc en quelque
sorte il n'avait pas non plus participé
à revigorer la démocratie que pensez
vous de ces propos scandaleux
inacceptable et il contribue justement à
discréditer la politique
si le sua talent avait la carrière
politique de monsieur larcher ou de
beaucoup d'autres de nos collègues
ici il ne dirais pas cela nous avons
tous été des élus locaux
conforté par nos électeurs nous avons
dirigé des communes des départements des
régions
vraiment c'est par des propos de cette
nature qu'on détruit la démocratie et la
politique en particulier que dire du
silence du chef de l'état depuis
dimanche dernier qu'est ce que les
pensées de la séquence qui a suivi le
premier tour où le président a un peut
vaquer à ses occupations sans revenir
sur ce chiffre de l'abstention
c'est malgré tout quelque chose de ne
pas pas compréhensible sans faire de
grands discours
il aurait pu quand même appelé les
français à voter pour qu'ils veulent
naturellement même et à aller voter
au moins sur le thème de la
participation je pense que le chef de
l'état aurait pu passer un message le
les patrons un d'adrexo et de
l'entreprise du distribution de la
propagande électorale ainsi que de la
poste doit être auditionné très
prochainement c'est même la prochaine
étape après gérald darmanin vous nous
l'annoncer votre commission denquête les
entendra également les fonctions de
coopération mais nationale qu'est ce que
vous allez poser comme question est-ce
qu'ils sont pas un peu le bouc émissaire
de cette affaire
il ya les dysfonctionnements ils sont de
caractère multiple le principal d'entre
eux c'est une distribution
catastrophique
donc il ya une part de responsabilité
d'internautes de ce point de vue là et
puis il ya d'autres sujets les
conditions de passation des marchés
le fait que se sont ouverts à la
concurrence pourquoi pas réfléchir à une
régie publique pour la distribution la
propagande électorale dont il ya aussi
d'autres sujets qui devraient être
abordés qui ne relève pas simplement de
la société adrexo ou de la poste oui
j'ai râlé dans maintenant il a dénoncé
par le fait que et bien c'était
compliqué d'organiser un double scrutin
comme c'est le cas cette semaine et que
effectivement et bien en fait c'est en
plus c'est une question qui peut vous
être renvoyés puisque le sénat avait
approuvé ces dates des 20 et 28 juin
qu'est ce que vous en pensez dès samedi
si cruellement sur ce point mais c'est
demain ce qu'il n'est pas juste l'année
dernière la métropole de lyon a été lui
aussi fragile et recel direct en même
temps que les élections municipales
les choses se sont passées de façon
normale
donc il y a eu en 2008 des élections qui
était également un double scrutin pas
sur tout le territoire sur une partie du
territoire
donc on sait faire il n'y a pas trop de
difficulté de ce point de vue là mais en
revanche la qualité de la distribution
la responsabilité de celui qui assure le
routage est entière et ça par contre
c'est le rôle du ministre de l'intérieur
que de le contrôler et de le vérifier en
quelques mots vraiment très rapidement
est-ce qu'il faut légiférer à nouveau
sur ce sujet laissant la commission
denquête faire son travail on en tire à
dérider grand recommandations peut-être
y aura des modifications c'est
effectivement très bien fait alors qu'on
entend les tambours cessé depuis
saleh des comptes et ancien a retrouvé
jérôme ramier restera pied dans l
hémicycle cela vous êtes en tribune de
presse jérôme dit nous ton du programme
s'il vous plaît à une séance de
questions d'actualité un qui va être
marquée par les élections régionales et
départementales en cette semaine d'entre
deux tours de nombreuses questions
prévues sur cette thématique une
question sur l'abstention massive sur
les dysfonctionnements vous venez d'en
parler dans l'envoi des professions de
foi des candidats et même une question
sur la nécessité nécessité ou non d'un
front républicain pour ce second tour
dans les autres sujets abordés il y
aurait également une question plusieurs
questions sur l'allocation adulte
handicapé le sénat avait voté la
déconvenue galles isation la majorité à
l'assemblée nationale l'a refusée à la
semaine dernière ce qui a provoqué
beaucoup de protestations dans les
différentes oppositions il y aura donc
deux questions sur ce sujet une venant
du loup démandé socialiste et une côté
les républicains on évoquera aussi un
notamment les intempéries dans les hauts
de france et c'est tout de suite puisque
la cloche vient de retentir
en séance a été distribué nous n'avons
pas aussi d'observation et en a t'il en
séance je n'en vois point de procès
verbal est donc adoptée sous les
réserves d'usagé
monsieur le premier ministre et dams et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues je voulais saluer et tony
estanguet président du comité
d'organisation des jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de paris 2024 qui est
présente dans notre tribune
[Applaudissements]
le 23 juin 1894 le baron pierre de
coubertin
réunis à la sorbonne les acteurs du
sport mondial avec pour objectif de
faire renaître des jeux olympiques
en 1948 le comité international
olympique choisi de commémorer cet acte
fondateur en organisant le 23 juin donc
ce jour la journée olympique qui est
depuis célébrée chaque année à cette
occasion et à un mois jour pour jour de
l'ouverture des jeux de tokyo
nous voulons apporter au nom du sénat
notre soutien aux 1400 athlètes et
accompagnateurs de la délégation
française
nous voulons adresser à l'équipe de
france regroupant les athlètes
olympiques et paralympiques un message
d'encouragement qui ont vu leur période
de préparation en jeu perturbé par la
crise que nous traversons le public
français sera co l'orne lors de chaque
olympiade unis derrière ces champions
notamment au travers des nombreuses
manifestations qui auront lieu sur
l'ensemble du territoire
à l'issue de ces jeux ce sera le 8 août
de cette année la flamme passera de
tokyo à paris pour la tenue en 2024 du
plus grand événement jamais organisé en
france qui est aussi une véritable
chance pour notre pays
monsieur le premier ministre vous
rappellera une mission que vous avez
conduit au delà de nos athlètes
je veux adresser ici un message de
sympathie à l'ensemble de la filière
sportive qui a été touché par de longs
moins de restrictions et je pense
notamment aux associations au sport
amateur et au sport professionnel
tel est le message que je souhaitais
vous adresser mes chers collègues ainsi
qu'à tous ceux qui nous regardent
aujourd'hui sur public sénat à
l'ouverture de notre séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mes chers collègues par lettre en date
de ce jour la commission des lois
demande au sénat en application de
l'article 5 ter de l' ordonnance du 17
mai 1958 relative au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires de lui
conférer les prérogatives attribuées aux
commission denquête pour une durée de
six mois afin de mener sa mission
d'information sur les dysfonctionnements
constatés dans l'organisation du premier
tour des élections départementales et
régionales du 20 juin 2021
la conférence des présidents a fixé à
demain 10h30 l'examen en séance publique
de cette demande at est donnée de cette
communication
notre ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
chacun sera attentif au respect des
valeurs essentielles du sénat le respect
des uns et des autres et celui du temps
de parole et je donne immédiatement la
parole d'un autre collègue thomas dessus
pour le groupe écologie solidarité et
territoires merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre cette question
s'adressait initialement à magna mise la
culture roselyne bachelot ce week-end un
jeune rennais de 22 ans avait décidé
d'aller danser après des mois de
couvre-feu et de confinement 7 à redon
avec quelques centaines de jeunes
s'il devait renouer avec la fête il y
perdra une main victimes de la
répression phénoménal de cette rave
victime une nouvelle fois d'une grenade
tirée de façon indéterminée dans la
foule
victime de méthodes de maintien de
l'ordre placé sous le régime de l
escalade de la violence
en plus des atteintes aux personnes les
forces de l'ordre ont aussi procédé à la
destruction de cent mille euros de
matériel musical à coups de hache dans
quel autre pays voit-on les forces de
l'ordre détruire du matériel musical
avec autant d'acharnement
en dehors de toute procédure et s'en
réjouir sur les réseaux sociaux
l'absence de réaction du ministère de la
culture démontre une nouvelle fois le
mépris vis-à-vis de cette scène et de la
jeunesse
il y a quelques semaines lors de la
présentation des protocoles stères de
déconfinement du monde de la culture
face à l'absence de perspective pour les
musiques actuelles et les concerts
debout je posais la question à roselyne
bachelot allons nous passer un été
culturel sous le signe de la répression
cela dit
t1 juin premier jour de l'été nous avons
enfin eu la réponse
plusieurs rassemblements festifs ont été
dispersés sous des pluies de grenades
lacrymogènes et de désencerclement après
un an et demi de confinement la jeunesse
de ce pays de faire la fête
elle veut communier mais n'a pas de
perspective claire à l'elysée lundi sous
les dorures on a pu danser avec jean
michel jarre dans la rue en revanche on
a matraqué et dispersé madame la
ministre
ma question est la suivante la politique
culturelle pour la jeunesse a été
sous-traitée à un ministre de
l'intérieur dont l'incompétence à
organiser des élections n'a d'égal que
son incompétence en matière de maintien
de l'ordre
son approche répressive vis à vis des
rassemblements festifs qui met en danger
notre jeunesse
va-t-elle être revu quelles sont les
perspectives culturelles pour notre
jeunesse est était fou quand vous
répondre la parole et sava secrétaire
d'état en charge de la jeunesse et de
l'engagement
madame sarah et la hérie vous avez la
parole madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur dessus la jeunesse
mérite mieux que des caricatures
depuis plus de dix ans monsieur le
sénateur les services de l'état jeunesse
intérieur culture santé organise des
médiations interministérielle avec les
organisateurs de fêtes et les
rassemblements festifs
monsieur le sénateur ce réseau de
médiateurs aujourd'hui est déployé sur
l'ensemble de notre territoire
des médiateurs qui permettent évidemment
notre jeunesse est bien de sortir de
vivre pleinement le dialogue et de
qualité entre l'état et les
représentants d'associations comme
freedom par exemple pour cet été bien
sûr nous sommes pleinement mobilisés
pour que la jeunesse profitent de
l'extérieur du retour à la fête mais
également respectant l'état de droit
qu'est le nôtre
monsieur le sénateur d'ahmed la ministre
de la culture aujourd'hui aurait pu
répondre à votre question mais les
retenu à l'assemblée nationale pour
défendre le projet de loi sur la
régulation à la protection de l'accès à
la culture sur la rave party monsieur le
sénateur on peut comprendre évidemment
l'envi de faire la fête mais les règles
sanitaires persiste les règles de notre
pays persistent et doivent être
respectées samedi 10
juin l'évacuation du teknival interdit à
redon et je le rappelle était interdit
par les forces de l'ordre ont été
réalisés avec des manoeuvres complexes
l'objectif est évidemment d'agir vite
d'agir rapidement et d'ailleurs j'en
profite pour saluer le calme
l'organisation et l'intervention des
forces de l'ordre certains individus ont
d'ailleurs été secourus par des unités
nautiques engagé par de ce dispositif
parce qu'il y avait d'un côté de l'eau
et de l'autre côté des habitants le
matériel de sonorisation devaient être
saisies monsieur le sénateur est très
rapidement pour faire fin à cette
infraction et permettre l'évacuation
dans le calme dans le cadre de la
procédure judiciaire de saisie il y a
évidemment il y a eu des dégradations
les faits seront établis sous l'autorité
du procureur de la république sous les
éventuels contentieux
monsieur le sénateur évidemment la
reprise et la réouverture est là dans le
cadre de la loi dans le cadre des règles
et c'est pour ça que la ministre de la
culture a également reçu l'ensemble des
festivaliers des acteurs de la culture
pour permettre un retour à la normale le
plus vite possible avec des jauges à
100% à l'extérieur avec la question dès
le 21 juin sous parce que souhaité par
le présent à appliquer le premier
ministre évidemment des acteurs des
concerts et des festivals je vous
remercie monsieur le sud quelques
secondes ah oui il fut un temps où les
autorités françaises vous l'avez 10
avait dialogué avec les ordinateurs
aujourd'hui vous privilégiez la matraque
c'est totalement irresponsable
la parole est à notre collègue jean
pierre decool pour le groupe des
indépendants république et territoires
vous avez la parole seul président le
ministre de l'intérieur mes chers
collègues le spectre d'une abstention
massive nous menacer pour une fois les
sondages ne se sont pas trompés et
l'ensemble de la classe politique a reçu
une douche froide
l'abstention a atteint un niveau
historique deux français sur trois ne se
sont pas exprimés n'est-il pas urgent
d'éclaircir les origines ce phénomène et
d'esquisser des pistes de réflexion au
delà des satisfactions des déceptions
politiques des uns et des autres le
couvent il a sa part de responsabilité
certes et le chemin dans les isoloirs
n'était peut-être pas la priorité des
français
si la grande gagnante est l'abstention
j'aimerais connaître à geler ou les
sources de cet étrange paradoxe
très souvent ils reprochaient notre
classe politique nationale d'être
éloigné du terrain mais quand vient le
temps des élections locales
les électeurs sont aux abonnés absents
on a connu les gilet jaune se plaindre
du manque de représentativité
on l'entend les jeunes se lamentait du
monde de rendez vous démocratique et
quand ces rendez vous sont fixés
ça fait pschitt plus personne pour les
honoraires comment expliquer cette
désaffection démocratique
je n'ai pas d'explication de
satisfaisante et les ratés de livraison
des professions de foi ne justifie pas
tout alors que nous disposons de moyens
de communication vertigineux je
m'interroge sur les modalités de
l'exercice démocratique
aussi n'est-il pas temps de se poser ou
se reposer officiellement certaines
questions
la concomitance de deux élections de
même jour était heureuse n'est-il pas
opportun de recourir à des solutions
technologiques face à un certain
archaïsme démocratique on admettant que
le vote par correspondance ou le vote
par internet même si beaucoup sont
réticents
n'est-il pas opportun de se poser la
question du vote obligatoire voire tu
votes blancs même si il n'est pas
forcément dans la démarche
constitutionnelle
quelle est cette majorité silencieuse
après 40 ans de vie politique locale
en tant qu'ancien maire d'une commune
rurale et vingt années de vie
parlementaire je suis comme nous tous
abasourdis
tu as cette désaffection des électeurs
merci pour ta réponse pour vous répondre
la parole les uns monsieur le ministre
de l'intérieur monsieur gérald darmanin
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
dessinateurs monsieur sénateur
jean-pierre decool évidemment
l'ascension nous choque tous nous choque
tous et des questions doivent se poser
puisque vous l'avez dit le silence est
là et ce silence veut dire quelque chose
et le silence vient de loin je rappelle
que pour les premières élections
régionales et 1 77 % de français qui ont
été votées à la fin des années 80 et que
nous constatons que prenons l'exemple de
une élection sans concomitance
l'élection qui n'a pas été reportée
l'élection ou les professions de foi
pour la plupart sont arrivés alors une
élection où il n'y avait pas de crise
que vides
seuls 50 % des français sont allés voter
c'est à dire plus de 20 points en plus
de vingt ans de d'abstention ces
élections locales ce qui est vrai pour
les élections locales puisque nous
l'avons déjà constaté aux municipales
monsieur le sénateur ou dans de très
nombreuses grandes villes de france
c'était le même niveau d'abstention que
2 mars dernier au premier tour j'entends
évidemment et bien sûr au second
lorsqu'il y en a eu nous constatons qu'à
l'élection présidentielle en revanche
même s'il ya une tendance à la baisse
il ya quand même 75% des français qui
vont aux urnes et bien sûr on peut se
poser la question de savoir si les
modalités peuvent être améliorées très
certainement de qu'elles peuvent être
améliorés en regardant le secret du
scrutin pour éviter les pressions
communautaires patriarcale familial mais
il faut évidemment réfléchir à la
modernisation du vote
nous pouvons nous penser aussi que c'est
pas simplement les modalités qui mène à
l'abstention mais aussi aux politiques
plus profonde qui touche l'occident
parce que tous les pays sont touchés et
singulièrement la france
choisir monsieur le sénateur que nous
devons y réfléchir bien sûr
collectivement après ce second tour des
élections régionales et départementales
avec un peu de recul mais le scrutin
n'est pas fini puisqu'il s'agira
dimanche prochain peut-être que la
concomitance des deux élections
souhaitées en 2015 n'était pas la
meilleure des solutions pour la bonne
compréhension de nos concitoyens
peut-être aussi que nous pourrions faire
bouger les lois qui nous permettent de
faire un seul bureau de vote par exemple
et qui permet de rendre plus clair un
certain nombre d'exercices de vote
peut-être que nous pourrions aussi
réfléchir bien sûr aux modalités du
scrutin et je suis évidemment à la
disposition du parlement et
singulièrement du sénat pour y réfléchir
merci la parole et à notre collègue
laurent duclos pour le groupe l'est
républicain
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur des enveloppes
de profession de foi dans les fossés et
dans les poubelles des enveloppes de
profession de foi empilés sur les boîtes
aux lettres des mairies des enveloppes
de profession de foi brûlé au coin des
chemins voilà la triste réalité d'une
distribution chaotique et inadmissibles
des documents de propagande
partout en france des millions
d'électeurs n'ont reçu aucun document
pourtant indispensable pour les informer
de la tenue des élections et pourrait
éclairer leur choix avec la crise
sanitaire privant les candidats de
moyens habituels de faire campagne
vous n'aviez aucun droit à l'erreur
quand on fait du quoi qu'il en coûte
son credo on ne lésine pas sur les
moyens après avoir affaibli le parlement
ait ignoré les corps intermédiaires
après avoir favorisé le tirage au sort
des concitoyens et l'établissement des
conventions citoyenne après avoir fait
du en même temps qu'ils contribuent à
donner le sentiment que même si on élit
quelqu'un ce sont d'autres qui sont
légitimes pour s'en occuper votre fiasco
de la distribution a abouti dimanche à
une abstention record
comment comptez vous monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur
stoppez votre hold up de la démocratie
pour vous répondre la parole et
pour ministre de l'intérieur monsieur
gérald darmanin monsieur le président
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur du plô j'ai entendu que
monsieur le président du sénat a évoqué
la commission denquête que vous allez
sans doute crée évidemment bien sûr par
les pouvoirs de l'assemblée sénatoriale
que vous représentez mais aussi par
volonté politique tout document par
nature et toute volonté
d'éclaircissement sera fait comme je les
crois a fait ce matin auprès du présent
du fait de sa commission dès potron
minet afin d'expliquer en effet qu'il ya
eu des dysfonctionnements graves dans
distribution de la propagande électorale
ces dix ans s'ouvre dysfonctionnements
graves dans propagande électorale à
notre connaissance et tout document
symphonie dès aujourd'hui à la
commission des lois touche 9 % depuis
non distribués pour les deux sociétés
qui ont gagné les marchés déclaré par
ces deux sociétés
la poste qui avait la moitié du marché
et l'autre moitié la société adrexo je
rappelle que ces deux directives
européennes de 97 et 2002 qui ont
libéralisé le service postal et
notamment éclaircissements fait mot pour
mot la propagande électorale que c'est
une loi de 2005 a obligé le gouvernement
à mettre en concurrence deux sociétés
seulement puisqu'il n'y a que deux
sociétés qui sont aujourd'hui validée
par une autorité administrative
indépendante qu'elle accepte
adrexo d'une part la poste d'autre part
vous évoquez les moyens ils ont été
doublé en dix ans pour la distribution
de trois grandes qui était grosso modo
150 millions d'euros en 2010 pour
atteindre 326 millions d'euros pour ce
budget s'ils y at-il eu des
dysfonctionnements
bien évidemment qu'il ya eu
dysfonctionnement tout à fait
inacceptables à plusieurs reprises nous
avons rappelé les deux sociétés et
singulièrement la société adrexo même si
le président de la poste lui même a fait
remarquer qu'il y avait aussi des
dysfonctionnements de son côté des
principalement dans la société adrexo
puisque des pluies non seulement n'ont
pas été distribués qui peuvent tenir à
la mauvaise distribution ce qui est tout
à fait imputable à la société à la
mauvaise tenue des listes électorales
qui dépend vous le savez bien du
ministère de l'intérieur dont j'en
prends ma part mais aussi la destruction
de propagande ce qui est absolument
inacceptable
il est évident que je répondrai à toutes
les questions que se posera bien sûr
votre commission monsieur du plomb
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur à
vous écouter vous n'êtes jamais en faute
et pourtant la vérité pour moi et que
votre gouvernement est coupable coupable
de ne pas avoir réagi en temps et en
heure a un problème sur lequel vous
étiez alerté depuis des semaines
coupable d'avoir mis sur ce coup de
miser sur ce coup de poker
en choisissant une entreprise au bord de
la faillite
pensant que l'abstention vous servent
alors qu'elle n'a finalement qu
amplifier votre élimination du second
tour dans plusieurs régions coupable de
jouer un jeu dangereux à vouloir réduire
le débat démocratique entre sa macro et
le diable l'open alors que le score des
régionales vous rappelle vos pires
cauchemars la droite républicaine dont
vous qui vous a mis au monde n'est pas
morte
merci la parole à notre collègue
philippe bonnecarrère pour le groupe
union centriste
vous avez la parole
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ma question
portera sur la position française à
l'égard de l'iran je voudrais la mettre
en perspective tout à l'heure nos
collègues de la commission de la défense
et des affaires étrangères
son président christian cambon or en
débat avec vous monsieur le premier
ministre sur les conditions de
souveraineté française sur la remontée
en puissance sur la révision de la loi
de programmation militaire et
l'association du parlement à celle ci
ils exprimeront probablement leur
préoccupation quant à l'évolution des
menaces et en particulier quant aux
risques de conflits dits de haute
intensité
une source majeure de conflit de haute
intensité vous le savez chers collègues
se situe au moyen orient avec
l'interférence de plusieurs états
puissance la relation entre l'occident
et l'iran est donc un sujet important
négociations de vienne est dissipée au
et changement politique aux etats unis
and israel élections le 18 juin du
président raïssi nucléaires balistiques
toutes ces questions sont interconnectés
ou années monsieur le ministre la
position française à l'égard de l'iran
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégué en charge du commerce
extérieur de l'attractivité monsieur
riester de la parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames les sénatrices
monsieur messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur bonnecarrère la
france a pris acte de l'élection de chez
brahim raïssi à la présidence de la
république d'iran le vendredi 18 juin ce
vendredi 18 juin le nouveau président
iranien prendra ses fonctions fin août à
la suite du président rohani la france
maintiendra bien évidemment à l'égard du
futur président iranien comme c'était le
cas avec son prédécesseur d attente
forte des positions claires d'abord
concernant les préoccupations que nous
avons régulièrement exprimé à titre
national mais aussi avec nos partenaires
européens concernant la situation des
droits de l'homme en iran
concernant la situation de nos
ressortissants détenus en iran
et nous continuerons avec beaucoup de
force à suivre cette situation dans les
semaines qui viennent et puis bien
évidemment des attentes fortes en
matière nucléaire puisque les
négociations qui sont engagées depuis
maintenant plusieurs années concernant
la perspective d'un retour à la pleine
mise en oeuvre de l'accord de vienne sur
le nucléaire de la part des états unis
qui en sont sortis et le changement
d'administration vous l'avez rappelé
change de ce point de vue là la donne
est bien sûr aussi de la part de l'iran
qui n'en respecte plus une partie
importante de ces dispositions la dispo
la diplomatie française est donc
pleinement mobilisés dans le cadre de
ses négociations avec nos partenaires
allemands britanniques ainsi qu'avec la
russie et la chine est en lien étroit
avec les états unis d'ailleurs jean yves
le drian rencontrera très prochainement
à paris son homologue blinken pour
notamment évoquer cette question des
négociations sur le nucléaire
nous souhaitons que ces négociations
puissent aboutir rapidement car le temps
ne joue pour personne dans cette crise
des décisions difficiles devront être
prises dans les prochains jours ou dans
les prochaines semaines si ces
négociations ne devaient pas avancé mais
au-delà de ces négociations sur le
nucléaire
nous avons des négociations sur le
retour des efforts de paix au sein au
moyen-orient' dans lequel évidemment la
france est très impliqué je vous
remercie monsieur votre carrière oui
monsieur prénom chers collègues je
voudrais souligner qu'avec l'iran les
choses sont rarement blanche ou noire
mais elles sont souvent blanches et
noires pour le volet noir pensons à nos
concitoyens
fariba adelkhah et benjamin brière qui
sont retenus dans des conditions
insupportables pour le volet blanc
pensons il existe aussi ce volet blanc
pensons rôle décisif des iraniens qui
ont arrêté des ch à erbil
aux côtés des kurdes pensons aussi
demain à l'espace de sécurité qu'ils
peuvent être pour nous par rapport à 2
de leurs voisins assez spécifiques
notamment l'égard de notre pays que sont
d'une part l'afghanistan et d'autre part
le pakistan merci la parole est à notre
collègue gérard lahellec pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologistes avaient la parole merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre chargée des personnes
handicapées jeudi dernier
vous vous êtes déshonorée en ayant
recours à la réserve de vote puis au
vote bloqué pour tordre le bras des
députés de votre majorité
cette manoeuvre procédurale est d'autant
plus scandaleuse que nous étions sur une
journée réservée à l'initiative
parlementaire et que la proposition de
loi émane du droit de pétition exercée
par nos concitoyens
mais sur le fond vous avez surtout
refuser de reconnaître l'autonomie des
personnes en situation de handicap en
refusant d'individualiser le calcul de
l'allocation aux adultes handicapés
vous avez préféré renvoyer chaque
personne dépendante du fait de ce
handicap à une autre forme de dépendance
la dépendance économique vis-à-vis de
leur compagne ou de leur compagnon de
vie si cette humiliation pour la
personne dépendante et pourtant dénoncée
par l'ensemble des associations au nom
de la responsabilité budgétaire le
gouvernement s'enferme dans une posture
bien éloignées des valeurs de progrès et
d'humanité ma question est donc la
suivante madame la ministre
allez vous inscrire à l'ordre du jour de
la session extraordinaire
la proposition de loi qui reconnaît
l'autonomie des personnes handicapées ou
préférez vous botter en touche en
prétextant l'examen du budget pour voté
un abattement fiscal sans rapport avec
l'individualisation de l'allocation
adulte handicapé
si pour vous répondre la parole à madame
la secrétaire d'état en charge des
personnes handicapées
madame sophie cluzel madame la ministre
je vais la parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur quel
dommage de voir tout ce travail commun
que le gouvernement a donné depuis le
début du quinquennat avec le parlement
avec les députés avec les sénateurs en
matière de handicap remise en cause au
nom de l'opportunisme politique
vous dites que le gouvernement fait
preuve de frilosité
preuve de frilosité budgétaire 2
milliards d'investissements sur ce
quinquennat pour l'allocation adulte
handicapé 2 milliards vous vous êtes
indignés sur la baisse de 5 euros des
appels et vous méprisez de l'autre côté
une augmentation de 100 euros par mois
de l'allocation adulte handicapé 100
euros de plus porté à 900 euros par mois
pour plus de 1 million de personnes non
monsieur le sénateur notre approche
n'est pas guidé par la seule volonté
budgétaire elle est guidée par le fait
d'assurer un système social basé sur des
principes de solidarité et de
redistribution
elle est guidée par la conviction que
les personnes en situation de handicap
ont des compétences qui sont des
citoyens à part entière et vous réduisez
un abattement fiscal au contraire une
avancée majeure pour les personnes une
avancée qui a tout à voir avec
l'autonomie puisque ses 110 euros plus 2
par mois en moyenne pour les
bénéficiaires qui sont en couple de la
hache c'est plus de 180 euros de gain
pour les couples dans le revenu du
conjoint est situé autour du smic au nom
des valeurs que votre groupe porte
vous devriez vous réjouir que l'on
flèche l'argent vers ceux qui en ont le
plus besoin et pas vers les plus aisés
comme le fait la déconvenue ganisation
quand notre mesure ne fait aucun parent
dans la vôtre prend l'âge des personnes
qui travaillent
nous portons une mesure de
simplification une mesure de justice
sociale
je souhaite bien évidemment que le texte
qui a été voté à l'assemblée puisse
aboutir
et c'est parce que je crois à cette
mesure redistributive au coeur de notre
adn politique que oui monsieur le
sénateur j'inscrirai cette avancée
majeure dans le budget d'état pour 2022
quoi qu'il arrive je l'inscrirai car le
gouvernement est fier de la politique
d'émancipation que nous portons depuis
2017 et parce que nous apporterons un
soutien constant au pouvoir d'achat des
personnes que je respecte profondément
bourbourg et monsieur là que vous avez
comme madame la ministre votre
entêtement imposer la prise en compte
des revenus des conjoints dans le calcul
de l'allocation adulte handicapé pour
faire des économies budgétaires est en
réalité dogmatique vous refuser la
proposition d'individualiser
l'allocation d'adulte handicapé dont le
chiffre est estimé à 750 millions
d'euros et vous défendez votre
proposition d'abattement fiscal de 200
millions qui ce n'est pas rien de 100
millions pour trouver les 500 millions
nécessaires il suffirait par exemple
d'imposer les dividendes des
actionnaires hauteur de 1 % par exemple
par exemple mais tout autre tout haut
leur proposition pourrait être la
bienvenue
voilà donc nous regrettons que le
gouvernement fasse ce choix
en tout cas nous saurons nous en
souvenir avec les associations des
personnes handicapées qui la parole est
maintenant notre collègue bernard but
pour le gros du rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes et indépendant
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre les dames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
du travail de l'emploi et de l'insertion
la filière automobile fait face depuis
plusieurs années à deux révolutions
technologiques écologiques qui ont
bouleversé son modèle économique
le président de la république a dévoilé
il ya un an un plan de soutien inédit à
la filière automobile durement touché
par la crise ce plan prévoyait plus de 8
milliards d'euros dead d'investissement
et de prêts pour soutenir et accompagner
la reconversion du secteur c'est
l'ambition du plan de relance préparé la
reprise en encourageant le développement
de l'industrie de demain tout en
accompagnant celles et ceux qui font
partie des secteurs sinistrés
vendredi dernier l'annoncé du lancement
du fonds d'accompagnement et de
reconversion des salariés de la filière
automobile marque une nouvelle étape
dans le déploiement du plan automobile
la signature de la convention entre les
acteurs de la filière permettra de
conforter le troisième volet du plan de
soutien à l'automobile annoncés au mois
de mai
dernier le ministre de l'économie l'a
rappelé la semaine dernière à
l'assemblée nationale avec le plan de
relance nous offrons une perspective aux
français celle d'un redressement
d'économies en deux ans qui doit nous
permettre de retrouver en 2022
le niveau de développement économique de
2019 tout en accompagnant les emplois
menacés vers les secteurs d'avenir
madame la ministre quelle est la place
du fonds d'accompagnement dans cette
perspective
et comment pouvons-nous faire en sorte
que les forces vives du secteur
automobile sont au coeur de la reprise
que nous appelons tous deux non veut on
vous répondre
la parole est très bas même la ministre
du travail de l'emploi et de l'insertion
madame elisabeth bord vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur bernard lui tout
d'abord je voudrais saluer votre
réélection dimanche dernier dès le
premier tour pour siéger au conseil
départemental de la drôme et j'en
profite pour féliciter toutes celles et
ceux qui ont été élus ou réélus dimanche
dernier alors vous l'avez rappelé face
aux mutations de la filière automobile
nous devons tous nous mobiliser pour
accompagner les salariés dans ces
transitions et c'est tout l'objet du
fonds d'accompagnement et de
reconversion des salariés de la filière
automobile
ce fonds est cofinancé à hauteur de 20
millions d'euros par les contes
constructeur renault estelle en tice et
de 30 millions d'euros par l'état
il permet de renforcer l'accompagnement
des salariés des entreprises de la
filière impacté par des restructurations
il s'adresse particulièrement aux
salariés des entreprises de la
sous-traitance automobile en
redressement ou liquidation judiciaire
ses salariés seront accompagnés de
manière renforcée par des cellules
territoriales d'appui au reclassement
concrètement cela pourra se traduire par
le financement de formations
qualifiantes des aides à la création
d'entreprise ou à la mobilité ou encore
des primes au reclassement
ce dispositif est d'ores et déjà
mobilisés
et pour les salariés de mbf dans le jura
dont je partage l'émotion
suite à l'annoncé de la liquidation de
leur entreprise
au delà de ce dispositif sectoriel nous
avons mis en place des moyens
conséquents pour la formation des
salariés 1 milliard d'euros sur le fn de
formation financés dans le cadre de
france relance avec transition
collective nous accompagnons également
la reconversion des salariés dont les
emplois sont menacés pour qu'ils
puissent être formés et rebondir vers
des secteurs qui recrutent dans le même
bassin d'emploi dont vous le voyez
monsieur le sénateur le gouvernement est
pleinement mobilisé pour permettre à
chaque salarié de rebondir rapidement je
remercie bernard but je suis heureux que
les entreprises sous traitantes ne soit
pas oublié c'était leur inquiétude et
particulièrement pour celles faisant
l'objet d'une procédure de redressement
ou de liquidation merci pour elle la
parole est maintenant notre collègue
jérôme durain pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicaine vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le président que
reste-t-il de l'état quand il n'est plus
capable d'assurer correctement le coeur
même de ses missions à savoir
l'organisation des élections le
ministère de l'intérieur est il bien
tenu voilà les questions que beaucoup se
posent depuis le scrutin de dimanche la
question s'adresse à monsieur darmanin
vous nous avez expliqué ce matin
monsieur le ministre qu'il était
compliqué pour notre pays d'organiser
deux élections le même jour j'ai compris
que vous faisiez référence à votre
propre expérience puisque en plus de vos
fonctions de ministre vous étiez
candidat deux fois aux élections de
dimanche dernier
[Musique]
pendant ce temps des élus de tous bords
et de tous les territoires ont constaté
des plis non distribués jetés dans les
fossés brûlé dans les bois le corps
préfectoral lui même nous a même parfois
fait part de sa honte par rapport à
l'image que l'état renvoie de lui-même
vous répondiez dimanche avec les
chiffres communiqués par adrexo qui
annonçait 21 puis à 21 milles plis non
distribués dans ma seule région de
bourgogne franche comté j'aurais pu vous
annoncer dès dimanche soir qu'on
dépasser ce chiffre
alors si l'on en croit le ministère de
l'intérieur la responsabilité de ces
dysfonctionnements notamment celles
d'adrexo reviennent petit à à lionel
jospin petit b à la poste peut tisser au
parlement qui a autorisé la tenue de ce
scrutin par vote
et comme dans tous les bons
questionnaire plusieurs réponses sont
possibles puisque c'est la faute de tout
le monde sauf la vôtre monsieur le
ministre il reviendra à la commission d'
enquête du sénat de définir l'ampleur
des dysfonctionnements observés dimanche
je voulais vous poser une question très
politique à quel taux de non
distribution de la propagande électorale
estimez-vous que votre propre
responsabilité est engagée
pour nous répond la parole et au
ministre de l'intérieur je suis gérald
darmanin
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur 7h ce
matin vous avez participé à la
commission des lois et je pense que vous
avez effectivement bien suivi les
échanges que nous avons eus il est un
fait établi que la privatisation de la
distribution du courrier et que dans la
distribution du courrier la propagande
électorale a été négocié par le
gouvernement que vous soutenez à
l'époque a été fait entre 97 et 2002 il
est à fait établi que depuis 2005 nous
avons un marché public qui s'impose au
ministère de l'intérieur pour la mise en
place de la propagande électorale et il
est un fait établi
monsieur le sénateur qu'il y a toujours
eu des dysfonctionnements pas la hauteur
de ce que nous avons connu c'est une
évidence puisque je prenais rien exemple
que des communes entières je prends
l'exemple de la ville d'annecy dans des
dernières élections n'ont pas eu par
exemple de distribution de propagande
électorale
il est par ailleurs un fait établi qu'il
n'y a que deux sociétés qui sont
aujourd'hui validée par l'arcep une
autorité administrative indépendante
pour répondre au marché que le ministère
de l'intérieur doit mettre en place en
vertu de la loi et des directives
européennes et par définition les deux
lots qui pour plus de 200 millions
d'euros
effectivement doit donner à deux
sociétés différentes monsieur le
sénateur s'il ya deux sociétés seulement
valider et qu'on doit mettre en
concurrence parce qu'on peut plus le
faire en régie parce que c'est la loi de
marché il est donc évident que deux
sociétés y répondent que nous puissions
dire à des sociétés comme la société la
poste mais encore plus responsable
la société adrexo qui est responsable
des plis l'eau distribuée que nous avons
tous vu sur les images et réseaux
sociaux et qui sont remontés que lé
responsable qu'une partie du marché ne
doit pas être payée voir pour révoque ce
marché c'est une évidence attendant
l'élection de dimanche
parce que je ne suis pas de ceux qui
aujourd'hui alors que les gens
distribuer ces propagandes souhaitent
les démotiver particulièrement alors
qu'ils essaient de redresser la barre
qui est effectivement bien mal en point
mais je veux dire monsieur le sénateur
que si vous regardez le taux de
participation dans les bureaux de vote
où la poste a distribué et le taux de
tous et adrexo il ya un point de
différence de participation j'aurais
tout le loisir de le démontrer devant la
commission d' enquête
monsieur du calvinisme votre
responsabilité ne s'arrête pas à la
question de la propagande officielle
les sénateurs socialistes vous avait
alerté sur l'ampleur de l'abstention à
venir nous avions proposé dans cinq
textes épars 30 amendements des
solutions alternatives et allemands du
vote sur plusieurs jours vote par
correspondance la proche de ces
élections a été un fiasco
nous avons notre fonction record dans
l'histoire de la république votre
responsabilité est évident qu évidemment
engagés sur tous ces points merci la
parole et un autre collègue christian
bilhac pour le rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
la parle merci monsieur le président le
président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre en charge des comptes publics
de nombreux maires de l'hérault ont
récemment protester contre la diminution
des horaires d'ouverture des bureaux de
poste mais également contre la
transformation du bureau de poste en
agence postale communale sida les
communes les plus rurales il est
compréhensible de voir les jeunes
postale assuré les services de proximité
cette évolution devient plus contestable
dans des communes de 3000 ou 4000
habitants sans oublier les fermetures
surprise de certains bureaux ou encore
l'insuffisance de la compensation
financière versée par la poste commune
pour les adresses postales communales en
effet selon le récent rapport
d'information de nos collègues patrick
chaize pierre loup et rémy chardon
le déficit en 2020 des quatre missions
de service public confiée à la poste
c'est vers la somme de 2 millions 103 2
milliard 103 millions d'euros soit un
billard 320 pour le service universel
postal 296 millions pour le transport la
distribution de la presse
227 millions pour l'aménagement du
territoire et 260 millions pour
l'accessibilité bancaire
mais monsieur le ministre la poste a
reçu les taxes 503 millions en
compensation
ce qui représente un déficit de 1
milliard 600 millions d'euros
difficile
dans ces conditions de maintenir le
service public
ma question est la suivante quand envie
de vous monsieur le ministre de mettre
fin à cette situation
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégué en charge des comptes
publics
monsieur olivier du soft vous avez la
parole merci si le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur bihac le sujet que vous évoquez
a fait l'objet d'un courrier de votre
part vous n'avez dressé il ya quelques
jours à la fin du mois de mai au sujet
de la présence postale et de la
réorganisation en cours du groupe la
poste
vous le savez parfaitement là la poste
est régi par une loi de 2010 qu'il
impose un certain nombre d'obligations
lié au service universel à la formation
d'accessibilité avec l'obligation de
maintenir au moins dix sept mille
bureaux et points de contact sur le
territoire et l'obligation aussi quelque
90 % de la population soit 100 km aux
puces ou 20 minutes au plus de ces
points de contact
il ya aussi des obligations matières
service universel de distribution cinq
jours sur sept
ces obligations sont un cadre qui peut
être exercés soit directement soit dans
le cadre d' agences postales communales
dans le cadre là aussi deux conventions
avec les communes ou à travers deux
points de contact en association avec
des commerçants malgré cela la poste
connaît des difficultés
le nombre d'objets colis ou courrier
qu'elle a eue qu'elle a à traiter
annuellement a été divisé par deux de 18
à 9 milliards entre 2008 et 2010 9 et le
nombre de courrier prioritaire adressé
par chaque ménage chaque année a été
divisé par sept
cela se traduit par des déficits et ça
se traduit par une nécessité de
réorganiser le service postal et que la
poste puisse aussi transformer ses
métiers elle s'y emploie par une
réorganisation territoriale par des
partenariats zac rue mais aussi par la
multiplication d'activités une forme de
diversification pour accompagner cette
réorganisation le gouvernement et l'état
répondront présents le premier ministre
a eu l'occasion de le dire l occasion de
lui préciser en réponse à des
interrogations et des inquiétudes de la
présidente du conseil de syrte de la
commission de surveillance de la caisse
des dépôts et consignations l'ancien
député jean launay nous a remis un
rapport récemment le 28 mai qui trace un
certain nombre de pistes que nous
instruisons est-ce que la compensation
supplémentaire doit prendre une forme
budgétaire ou une forme fiscale est-ce
que ça doit être un mixte et ses
solutions
nous savons que ce projet ce problème
est devant nous le savons tous devant le
traité nous mettrons à profit le projet
de loi de finances pour 2022
pour mieux accompagner la poste répondre
aux inquiétudes et ainsi garantir sa
présence sur le territoire et un bon
niveau des services à l'ensemble des
usagers jubile ac
j'entends bien monsieur le ministre mais
je tiens à rappeler combien la porte est
importante dans les territoires ruraux
mais aussi dans les quartiers difficiles
dans les quartiers sensibles
ce service public est à la fois
historique et les français sont très
attachés
alors vous vous retrancher un père
derrière la cep mais pour lâcher
manoeuvre du territoire ces 50 millions
de moins que le chiffre à l'arcep ou
versés à la poste alors s'il vous plaît
respectez le chiffrage de l'arcep
merci la parole est à notre collectif et
nec pour le groupe l'est républicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
comment en sommes-nous arrivés là nous
avons atteint dimanche les taux de
participation les plus bas de l'histoire
de la république
sur un plan personnel je ne vais pas me
plaindre chez moi nous avons remporté un
large succès fruit de notre travail au
quotidien sur le terrain
mais si l'on prend un peu de hauteur
c'est un vrai déni démocratique et vous
avez au gouvernement une lourde
responsabilité
la première responsabilité c'est une
campagne d'information minimaliste sur
l'existence de deux scrutins locaux
bien sûr vous êtes la réalité c'est vous
êtes en campagne présidentielle monsieur
le président est d'ailleurs en pleine
tournée électorale et vous avez donc
choisi de mettre sous le boisseau ces
deux scrutins
d'ailleurs vous êtes allé jusqu'à
annoncer la date des présidentielles
entre les deux tours c'est dire à quel
point ça vous obsède
ah c'est vrai vous avez tout de même
découvert le charme des hôtes france
musique vous y avez envoyé pas moins de
cinq ministres comme par hasard sur le
terrain d'un des concurrents de droite
qui semble pour vous sans doute le plus
dangereux ce qui prouve encore que nous
vous ne penser qu'aux présidentielles
la deuxième responsabilité celle à faire
de la propagande électorale ça a été
évoqué il ya deux ans le gouvernement
voulait la supprimer
cette fois il a imaginé pire il a
demandé aux candidats d'écrire et
d'imprimer leur profession de foi au
moment où ils déposent leur candidature
alors que la profession de foi ses
documents de campagne de dernière minute
par excellence
alors en plus ça a été dénoncé certains
sont arrivés en un mois avant le scrutin
et d'autres ne sont jamais arrivés vous
avez tué la mobilisation électorale
la troisième responsabilité c'est
l'intervention de monsieur le premier
ministre en provence côte d'azur sur la
fusion des listes et l'air est en marche
opération qui a fait flop mais qui a
provoqué l'incompréhension
le désintérêt voire le dégoût de
lectorat
mais puisque vous avez été la peau de ce
prêt une liste du front républicain
alors que la gauche vient de passer des
accords avec l'extrême gauche pour
garder ses présidences pourquoi on vous
entend pas pour les dénoncer
pourquoi ne pas demander à vos listes en
marche de se retirer
offert force contre cette tendance
radicale islamo-gauchiste ma question
comment justifier comment justifiez-vous
ce passage à la trappe de ces deux
scrutins et comment comptez-vous faire
barrage à la présence d'élus d'extrême
gauche prônant la révolution le
communautarisme et qui maintenant veut
mettre le feu à la france merci pour
vous répondre la parole et aux milices
de l'intérieur monsieur le président
monsieur 17 heures monsieur le 7 à 2 et
vous comprendrez aisément que je me
borne à répondre dans l'organisation du
scrutin qui est en responsabilité pour
ma part deux sélections départementales
et régionales
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire ce matin
devant la commission s'est aussi infect
pourront largement évoqué j'imagine dans
la commission denquête que pour la
première fois depuis 1986 la france a
organisé deux scrutins sur tout le
territoire national en même temps
puisque dans les autres dates que l'on
me cite en général les élections qu'on
appelait jadis cantonales étaient sur la
moitié du territoire depuis 1986
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
depuis 1986 la france n'a jamais
organisé deux scrutins en même temps
puisque lorsque les cantonales étaient
organisées c'était sur la moitié du
territoire
deuxième chose que je voudrais évoquer
avec vous la plupart de nos voisins
européens qui ont un système
démocratique tout à fait semblable au
nôtre à quelques exceptions près par
exemple ils n'ont pas tous deux tours
d'élections par exemple et non pas tous
que cinq jours entre les deux tours par
exemple une partie d'entre eux ont mis
en place un centre de dispositions
différentes pour le vote
la plupart de ces pays ont reporté leur
élection et ne les ont pas briser en
2021 notamment les élections locales
c'était le cas en italie par exemple
pourra pas le citer la plus grande
démocratie qui était inquiète à deux
portes
troisième sujet j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire nous avons eu un débat long je
crois que chacun peut en témoigner pour
sas nous osions tenir ces élections qui
ont été reportés et qui ont été même
reporté par deux fois reporté une
première fois à cause de la crise
coville une deuxième avec le décalage
par le décret pour permettre un maximum
de vaccination je constate d'ailleurs
que la question se pose sur la
propagande
ce que je comprends tout à fait j'aurais
l'occasion largement demandes expliqué
au nom du gouvernement mais que les
présidents à ce centre de vote ont été
vaccinées que les tests ont été faits
que tous les bureaux ont été ouverts à
l'exception de quelques-uns à marseille
et vous le savez bien en responsabilité
de la vie municipale et pas des
représentants de l'état et le
responsabilité revient en premier lieu
aux maires de france qui ont su
organiser dans des concerts croissance
absolument exceptionnel ce scrutin y
compris dans les territoires où il ya eu
des inondations extrêmement graves comme
le sud de l'aisne ou que le département
de l'essonne
voilà monsieur le sénateur ce que je
souhaitais vous apporter comme réponse
la parole est maintenant me pré-collecte
madame martine filleul pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste
[Applaudissements]
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
premier ministre
l'an dernier les sinistres occasionnés
par les intempéries ont coûté 1,5
milliard d'euros un montant supérieur à
la moyenne de ces quarante dernières
années
or la situation s'aggrave je n'en veux
pour preuve que les récentes inondations
causées par de violents orages dans
plusieurs départements
engendrant de graves dégâts et de
nombreuses victimes
les maires des communes concernées
demandent la reconnaissance de l'état de
catastrophe naturelle
ces conséquences croissante du
changement climatique met sous tension
le régime dit cat nat et démontre la
nécessité d'assurer sa pérennité
à notre demande une mission
d'information relative à la gestion des
risques et à l'évolution de nos régimes
d'indemnisation a été mis en place au
sénat en 2019 rapporteur de cette
mission notre collègue nicole bonnefoy
et le groupe socialiste ont déposé une
proposition de loi adoptée à l'unanimité
au sénat
pour mieux protéger à accompagner les
victimes pour déplafonner le fonds
barnier renforcer le pouvoir des maires
toujours en première ligne dans ces
circonstances
malheureusement ce texte n'a pas été
soutenu par votre gouvernement qui n'a
pas souhaité l'inscrire à l'ordre du
jour de l'assemblée nationale
mais le comble c'est qu'un texte
étrangement similaire a été déposé
pire encore le projet de loi climat est
totalement silencieux sur ces questions
alors même qu'il existe un titre censé
traiter de l'adaptation des territoires
au changement climatique
il y a urgence cependant alors monsieur
le premier ministre quand allez vous
reconnaître l'état de catastrophe
naturelle pour ces territoires
quand allez-vous prendre sérieusement ce
sujet en considération et apporter des
réponses législatives et financières
nécessaires
pour vous répondre la parole et à la
ministre de la transition écologique
madame barbara propylique merci monsieur
le président mesdames et sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice fille vous avez raison ce
genre d'événements climatiques extrêmes
risquent de se multiplier se multiplient
déjà et nous devons en tirer des
conséquences
d'abord il faut en tirer des
conséquences immédiates vous l'avez dit
nous avons eu des secours qui ont été
engagés sur le terrain et que je tiens à
saluer pour pour leur efficacité dans de
nombreux départements notamment du nord
de la france
ensuite il faut que nous prenions des
décisions sur comment être plus
résilient à l'avenir face à cela il faut
que nous mettions en place d'abord des
indemnisations plus pérenne le fonds
barnier a été augmentée de 50% 2021 pour
atteindre 205 millions d'euros
c'est l'urgence mais évidemment nous
n'avons pas tous réglés comme cela le
plus important c'est maintenant de
prévenir en réduisant la vulnérabilité
de nos territoires en diminuant et c'est
une des mesures phares du projet de loi
climat résilience peut-être que on n'en
parle pas suffisamment mais en réduisant
l'artificialisation des sols
nous savons que l'artificialisation des
sols est une des cause grave des
inondations puisque elle aggrave ces
inondations à cause notamment du
ruissellement et puis fait que ça
empêche l'eau tout simplement de rentrer
sous terre insolent imperméabilisées
c'est une des premières causes des
catastrophes que nous vivons aujourd'hui
je regrette d'ailleurs que lors de
l'examen en commission la
territorialisation objectif de division
par deux d'ici 2030 du rythme
d'artificialisation a été remise en
cause ici outre le projet de loi je
voudrais aussi mentionné les
investissements de l'état une météo
france à hauteur de 140,4 millions
d'euros pour développer les capacités de
prévisions ou encore un dispositif d'
alerte vigicrues flash qui est
disponible depuis le mois de mai et
j'incite tous le monde à prévenir les
élus locaux qu'ils peuvent s'inscrire
sur ces alerte vigicrues flash qui
permet de faire gagner un temps précieux
aujourd'hui seuls 15% des maires se sont
abonnés il y aura encore bien d'autres
sujets nous pourrons en parler lors de
l'examen du projet de loi climat et
résilience mai
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
cherche pas varient pour le groupe l'est
républicain vous avez la parole
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le délégué chargé du commerce
extérieur de l'attractivité monsieur le
ministre
partout dans le monde l'activité repart
et des économies se relance après la
crise sanitaire en france nous assistons
à un rebond technique après
l'effondrement de 8% du pib
sa progression devrait atteindre 6%
cette année une écurie partielle de la
situation pourrait nous conduire à un
excès d'optimisme même toute comparaison
montrapon à quel point notre économie
ressorts de la crise plus dégradée que
celle de nos voisins nos parts de marché
à l'exportation régresse ces chiffres
sont mauvais déclariez vous en février
dernier en effet pour l'année 2020 les
chiffres publiés par la direction
générale des douanes traduisent une
inquiétante dégradation
le déficit commercial de la france qui
était déjà de 57,9 milliards d'euros en
2019 atteint désormais 65,2 milliards
les exportations françaises de biens et
services se sont contractés plus
fortement que dans les autres pays de la
zone euro moins 19,3 pour cent à
comparer au moins 13 j'annule 2 pour la
zone euro le déficit commercial de la
france s'est aggravée pour atteindre 3
6% du pib alors que les soldes de
l'espagne et l'italie s'améliorer quant
à l'allemagne elle maintient un excédent
de 5 5% de son pib la part de la france
dans les exportations de la zone euro
est à son plus bas depuis 20 ans et les
chiffres de 2021 continue à se dégrader
ce qui est encore plus grave c'est que
cette détérioration concerne la quasi
totalité des catégories de produits y
compris maintenant le secteur
agroalimentaire quelles conclusions
tirer de ces résultats désastreux la
compétitivité de nos entreprises s'est
dégradée la fiscalité française est plus
que jamais désavantageuse par rapport
aux autres pays de notre industrie
poursuit son érosion
monsieur le ministre le déclassement
français est il donc inéluctable
personne ne peut s'y résoudre et nous
attendons des actions fortes de votre
part
merci pour vous répondre la parole et
mobilise délégué en charge du commerce
extérieur de l'attractivité
merci monsieur le président mesdames
dessinatrice messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur baril c'est vrai
que le déficit commercial extérieur de
la france s'est dégradée en 2020 par
rapport à 2019 vous imagine bien qu'avec
la crise qu vides et des secteurs qui
sont des secteurs forts à
l'international pour la france qui ont
été particulièrement touchés par la
crise coville comme l'aéronautique nous
a conduits à voir ses résultats en
dégradation en 2020 pour autant la
france est absolument mobilisés pour
redresser ce commerce extérieur français
qui structurellement déficitaire depuis
des années sur quatre axes 1 la
compétitivité et pardon monsieur le
sénateur je sais que vous connaissez
bien ces questions là mais non la
compétitivité des entreprises françaises
ne se dégradent pas au contraire elles
s'améliorent elles s'améliorent
notamment par les décisions fiscales qui
ont été prises par le gouvernement
depuis 2010 est la baisse de la
fiscalité sur le capital la baisse de
l'impôt sur les sociétés la baisse des
impôts de production
le rapprochement des négociations au
sein des entreprises du terrain la
simplification de la relation des
entreprises avec l'administration le
pack est mis sur la formation
professionnelle et sur l'innovation
permettent à la france pour la deuxième
année consécutive d'être le pays le plus
attractif en matière d'investissements
étrangers sur son sol en 2020 après 2019
et on aura l'occasion de l'heure dont on
aura l'occasion d'en reparler lundi dans
le cadre du grand événement tous france
sur l'attractivité de la france
le deuxième axe est la stratégie
industrielle nous devons avoir une
stratégie industrielle encore plus forte
que nous l'avions eu les années
précédentes c'est le tout l'objectif du
plan de relance france relance qui mise
sur les secteurs industriels d'avenir
c'est aussi d'avoir une politique
commerciale européenne moins naïve en se
dotant d'outils pour mieux protéger nos
entreprises et sont au coeur des
initiatives françaises pour revoir la
politique commerciale européenne et nous
aurons d'ici à la présidence française
des outils juridiques pour démontrer que
les choses changent en europe et
lanfains bien évidemment
l'accompagnement des entreprises des pme
monsieur le sénateur je sais que vous
êtes particulièrement attachés à leur
devenir
les pme qui doivent être mieux
accompagner à l'international et c'est
au coeur du plan de relance export que
j'ai l'honneur de porter depuis
maintenant plus de six mois au sein du
gouvernement
merci la parole était notre collègue
crédit pour le groupe de l'union
centriste avait la parole monsieur le
président où c'est le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chefs pour les gueux rama la question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de la
transformation et de la fonction
publique madame la ministre
depuis ma première mandature sera depuis
2015 je suis continuellement interpellé
par des fonctionnaires titulaires
polynésiens qui émettent le voeu de
rentrer servait dans leur territoire
d'origine
après plusieurs années d'affectation
métropole loin de leurs familles premier
thème de rappeler que la polynésie
française se situe à dix mille
kilomètres de l'hexagone et qu'il faut
traverser deux océans pour visiter la
famille et un cours prohibit et pour nos
fonctionnaires
certes il ya eu des évolutions mais
comprenez bien qu'il est tout à fait
normal pour un enfant du pays des
maîtres le voeu de pouvoir travailler
dans la collectivité dont il est
originaire dès lors qu'il ya une vacance
d'emploi correspondant à son grade dans
son administrations déconcentrées en
polynésie or force est de constater que
malgré la loi du 20 avril 2016 relatives
à la déontologie et aux droits et
obligations des fonctionnaires et la loi
et rome
égalité de l outre-mer d'identifier 2010
cet institut le caractère prioritaire je
pèse mes mots du retour en outre m
pour le critère du cmm centre des
intérêts matériels et moraux
certains ministères techniques ignore ce
principe est privilégiée l'affectation
de fonctionnaires expatriés au détriment
de nos enfants y travaillent et qui ont
fait l'effort de passer les concours à
l'échelon national et l'effort de
s'expatrier en métropole sont les
avantages fournis uniquement dans le
sens paris papeete
de tels agissements de la bureaucratie
parisienne nous laisse pantois en
polynésie et me dit sincèrement d'être
dénoncés ainsi que comptez-vous faire
madame la ministre pour que les
fonctionnaires ultramarins sort
définitivement considéré comme
prioritaire dans leurs voeux de mutation
à destination de la territoire d'origine
pour vous répondre
l'économiste de la transformation merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice têtu a nui d'abord depuis le
début du quinquennat vous le savez le
gouvernement est entièrement mobilisé
pour une fonction publique plus
représentative de l'ensemble des bassins
de vie dont nous avons la responsabilité
dans cet esprit nous sommes engagés à
faciliter quand il le souhaite le retour
des fonctionnaires originaires d
outre-mer dans leur territoire
je tiens donc ici a rappelé un principe
fondamental comme tout fonctionnaire
ultramarins pour son territoire les
fonctionnaires d'origine polynésienne
sont bien prioritaire pour accéder aux
emplois de la fonction publique en
polynésie à cette fin l usage du critère
du centre des intérêts matériels et
moraux
le seuil est même que vous mentionnez
comme priorité légal d'affectation
permettant le retour de fonctionnaires
dans leur territoire d'origine est
particulièrement important et en tant
que mise à fonction publique je
m'attache à promouvoir ce dispositif
avec force auprès nos agents publics
comme le prévoit la loi de 2019
je vous remets très dans les tout
prochains jours un rapport sur ce sujet
vous y verrez que nous y faisons un
bilan de ce qui a été mis en place
depuis 2010 est et que cette priorité
légal récente constitue une véritable
accélération des possibilités de
mutation pour les agents qui les
sollicitent en effet depuis 2017
les demandes effectuées au titre du
centre d du sens des intérêts matériels
et moraux abouti dans 28% des cas une
affectation
ce qui est le double des affectations
attribués au titre des autres priorités
comme par exemple la situation de
handicap ou le rapprochement familial
autrement dit le sens des intérêts
matériels et moraux et bien dans
l'application de notre droit la priorité
des priorités
en polynésie spécifiquement il apparaît
que certains agents qui souhaitent
revenir ne font pas à 0
à ce dispositif je cherche donc avec les
employeurs publics à s'assurer qu'ils
ont bien toute l'information
je m'y attache parce que vous le savez
de nombreux postes sont ouverts dans les
différentes des potes territoires et
départements d'outre-mer notamment avec
aujourd'hui 1800 postes sur la place de
l'emploi public ouverts dans les
collectivités départements d'outre-mer
dont vous voyez mal à la sénatrice avec
mes collègues ministres
nous allons continuer à oeuvrer pour cet
enjeu crucial de l'agent public dans les
autres mers je vous en remercie merci la
parole est maintenant à notre collègue
pascale gruny pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au premier ministre la semaine
dernière au terme d'une séance
surréaliste et d'un passage en force du
gouvernement l'assemblée a refusé de
séparer les revenus du conjoint de
l'allocation aux adultes handicapés dit
h en ayant recours au vote bloqué vous
avez empêché la tenue d'un débat
légitime sur notre système de solidarité
vous avez exprimé une nouvelle fois
votre peu de considération à l'égard du
parlement mais surtout à l'égard de tous
ceux qui depuis longtemps se bat pour
l'autonomie financière des personnes
handicapées car le mécanisme actuel de
calcul de la hache est injuste le
bénéficiaire qui est en couple se voit
privée de son allocation dès lors que
les revenus comme un excès d'un plafond
de ressources
ils se retrouvent un extrême dépendance
pour les dépenses quotidiennes
je pense aux femmes handicapées dans les
revenus sont généralement plus faibles
que ceux de leurs conjoints
je pense aux personnes qui font le choix
de ne pas se mettre en couple pour ne
pas perdre leurs allocations
je pense à ceux qui n'ont parfois
d'autres choix que de se séparer pour
retrouver leur indépendance financière
le sénat s'est prononcé le 9 mars
dernier en faveur de cette mesure de
justice sociale
répondant au succès d'une initiative
citoyenne sur la plateforme i pétition
voulue par notre président gérard
larcher pour établir un contact direct
avec nos concitoyens
ma question est simple monsieur le
premier ministre allez vous revenir sur
votre position moralement regrettable en
acceptant enfin de supprimer les revenus
du conjoint dans le calcul de la hache
merci pour vous répondre la parole et
karbala mme la secrétaire d'état
on cherche des personnes handicapées
malades plus elle merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs et sénatrices madame la
sénatrice grenier je me demande bien
qu'est ce qui a pu se produire entre
octobre 2018 est aujourd'hui pour que
votre groupe politique balaie d'un
revers ces principes
permettez-moi de vous rappeler qu'en
2018 dans ce même hémicycle
vous étiez le groupe qui a affirmé à
propos de la dea conjugale isation je
cite la volonté de nier la situation
familiale du bénéficiaire pour un
individu et individualiser la location
participe de cette vision individualiste
de l'homme et de la société qui tend
vers un éclatement du lien social et une
déconstruction de la famille vous vous
opposiez massivement par principe au nom
des valeurs qui font votre colonne
vertébrale politique à la dé conjugale
isation et à ses effets ou vous refusiez
à considérer la société comme une simple
addition d'individus autonomes aux
intérêts propres
mais où sont donc passés ces principes
de solidarité nationale et familiale
madame la sénatrice
considérez-vous également à présent le
couple comme une zone de violences
permanentes ou les personnes en
situation de handicap sont
systématiquement présentée comme soumise
ou sous emprise
parlons également de responsabilité
budgétaire vous vous érigez en
permanence sont garants du bon usage des
derniers plus des deniers publics
vous passez votre temps à nous donner
des leçons de gestion vous êtes prêt à
ouvrir la voie la voie un revenu
universel sans conditions de ressources
et par conséquent à ouvrir ce principe
aux récents sur les budgets des
départements
pour rappel cd conjugale isation durée
ça est chiffrée à 9 milliards ce nous
les ajoutons au coût de la déconvenue
ganisation je serai très curieuse de
connaître votre stratégie budgétaire
alors nous fine allons-nous financer des
hausses avec les impôts des français et
bien non la réforme que nous portons
c'est zéro perdant ses 110 euros de plus
pour les coupes pour cent vingt mille
personnes en couple c'est aucune
promesse vaine car nous pouvons
l'appliquer de le premier je vais
2011-2020 ont toute équité et justice
sociale
madame la présidente
loli merci sur l'esprit budgétaire quand
on est dans le quoi qu'il en coûte je
pense que pour des personnes en
situation de handicap
on ne fait pas de détails sur ce que
nous avions fait en 2018 simplement vous
le savez il ya une partie en fait des
personnes handicapées qui s'ils ont
justement on sépare les revenus vont
perdre et on voulait cette étude
d'impact donc pour nous il n'y a pas de
souci on a revu sa position le texte est
prêt on est à votre disposition
nous aurons l'occasion de revenir et
avec l'ensemble des bancs vous verrez
que on le passera nous on ne fait pas de
politique politicienne sur la situation
du handicap
merci la parole est à notre collègue
annie le héros prend le groupe
socialistes écologistes et républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le premier ministre madame la
ministre le 9 juin dernier je vous
interrogeait sur la réforme du chômage
et ses effets dévastateurs pour les plus
précaires
à cette occasion le gouvernement affirmé
qu aucun demandeur d'emploi ne seraient
pénalisées par cette réforme et qu'elle
se justifiait par une situation
économique favorable et un marché du
travail en très nette reprise hier le
conseil d'état infirme ses propos saisis
par les syndicats la juge des référés
suspens le mode de calcul proposée par
votre gouvernement et qui devait rentrer
en vigueur le 1er juillet prochain
la juge pointe les incertitudes
économiques qui ne permettent pas la
mise en place de ces nouvelles règles
cette réforme rend moins favorable la
démonisation du chômage des salariés
alternant contrats courts et une
activité ce nouveau contretemps pour
votre réforme arrive après l'échec des
négociations avec les partenaires
sociaux en 2018
malgré cela vous prenez un décret en
juillet 2019 qui redéfinit le régime
d'assurance chômage en novembre 2020 le
conseil d'état à annuler partiellement
ce dès ce décret vous en prenez un
nouveau le 30 mars 2021 amendant le mode
de calcul nouvelle saisine par les
syndicats et nouvelle suspension par le
conseil d'état qu'en pensez vous
abandonner ce bras de fer qui dure
depuis trois ans je rappelle que d'après
l'étude d'impact menée par l'unedic
un million cent cinquante mille
personnes constaterait une baisse
moyenne de 17% de leur allocation dont
345 milles jeunes qui peinent à trouver
un emploi stable
cette réforme est injuste et accentue
les inégalités
elle propose des économies sur les
chômeurs et en particulier sur les plus
précaires
une nouvelle fois nous vous le demandons
monsieur le premier ministre
abroger une bonne fois pour toutes cette
réforme injuste
pour vous répondre la parole intérêts de
l'ami du travail de l'emploi et de
l'insertion de la borde
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice annie le houérou
je vous remercie de me donner une
nouvelle fois l'occasion de le redire
aucun demandeur d'emploi ne verra son
allocation baissé dans le cadre de la
réforme
le montant global des allocations est
maintenu et seuls les demandeurs
d'emploi qui gagnent plus en étant au
chômage qu'en travaillant pourront avoir
demain une allocation plus basse qu'au
demeurant ils toucheront plus longtemps
alors je vous invite à relire la
décision du conseil d'état le conseil
d'état ne remet absolument pas en cause
la réforme de l'assurance chômage
il ne retient aucun des arguments au
fond soulevées par les organisations
syndicales
le conseil d'état nous dit que ce n'est
pas le bon moment pour modifier le mode
de calcul de l'allocation chômage car
selon son analyse la conjoncture
économique serait trop incertaine alors
pour ma part je constate que l'économie
repart que les embauches sont très
dynamiques et je pense madame la
sénatrice que vous entendez comme moi
des entreprises qui font état de
difficultés de recrutement
donc c'est maintenant qu'il faut faire
évoluer les comportements sur le marché
du travail et qu'il faut lutter contre
la précarité et je précise parce que
tout le monde ne semble pas l'avoir
compris que le bonus malus entrera en
vigueur dès le 1er juillet pour les
entreprises nous regardons donc comment
rassurer davantage tant sur la situation
économique que sur la dynamique de
l'emploi
nous préciserons dans les prochains
jours les modalités d'une mise en oeuvre
rapide de la réforme de l'assurance
chômage
dans l'immédiat nous allons publier un
décret pour prolonger les règles
actuelles de calcul de l'allocation
chômage faut que les demandeurs d'emploi
continue être indemnisé après le 1er
juillet mais l'ambition du gouvernement
restent inchangés accompagner la reprise
de notre économie
en répondant aux besoins de recrutement
des entreprises et lutter contre la
précarité notamment grâce à une mise en
oeuvre rapide de la réforme de
l'assurance-chômage remercie
allure aux échos nous n'entendons pas
les mêmes échos vous refuser de
reconnaître l'injustice de votre réforme
pointé par le conseil d'état merci la
parole est à notre collègue et shabunda
est clair pour le groupe l'est
républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la relance monsieur le
ministre la filière bois française est
aujourd'hui dans une situation critique
le plan de relance américain une forte
demande chinoise et bientôt russe dope
la demande de bois à l'échelle mondiale
avait pour conséquence une flambée des
prix sans précédent
ce qui n'est pas sans conséquences pour
notre pays
des grumes et des sciages de chênes et
de résineux sont trop massivement
exporté met en péril nos ressources
nationales les prix s'envolent car des
traders étrangers ou des moyens financés
bien supérieurs à ceux des acheteurs
français
les professionnels de la construction
bois les charpentiers et les menuisiers
de nos territoires ne peuvent plus
honorer leurs commandes des chantiers se
trouve à l'arrêt d'autres ne pourront
démarrer comme prévu face à ce phénomène
il est essentiel de trouver rapidement
des leviers d'action
même si nous savons que la situation est
complexe et que nos marges de manoeuvre
sont limitées
eu égard à la réglementation européenne
la semaine dernière dans le cadre des
débats sur la loi climat un amendement
qui restaure la carte professionnelle
d'exploitants forestiers a et 2 a été
adopté par le sénat
nous espérons que cette mesure sera
maintenue lors des débats à l'assemblée
nationale monsieur le ministre
quelles mesures comptez-vous mettre en
oeuvre pour établir cette situation
devenue critique et protéger les
entreprises françaises qui dépendent de
ce secteur je vous remercie on vous
répondre la parole est aux ministres de
l'ue
en charge du compte plus donc merci
monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice tricks clair vous l'avais dit
la situation est complexe et un certain
nombre de règles notamment
communautaires mais pas seulement c'est
un poste à nous et nous encadrent dans
la manière dont nous pouvons répondre
aux problématiques de la filière bois il
a deux difficultés une difficultés
conjoncturelles liées à la fois une
reprise très rapide partout dans le
monde mais aussi à des comportements
spéculatifs et face à des difficultés
d'approvisionnement ainsi qu'à
l'augmentation des coûts des matières
premières et du bois en particulier nous
avons travaillé avec le comité de
filière depuis le mois d'avril dernier à
la fois pour rappeler les grands
donneurs d'ordres à éviter les surstocks
mais aussi pour inciter les acheteurs
publics à ne pas appliquer des pénalités
sur les marchés qui serait retardé par
des problèmes d'approvisionnement
c'est ce que fera l'état il nous avons
invité les collectivités qui le
souhaiteraient dans le respect de la
libre administration à le faire aussi
par ailleurs nous sommes convaincus que
notre réponse doit pas seulement être
conjoncturelles d'autant plus qu' elle
s'inscrit dans le cadre que vous avez
évoqué mixte doit être une réponse
depuis long terme
cela passe par des outils très
transversaux vous avez évoqué les
dispositions de loi climat qui prouve
prospéreront au cours du débat
parlementaire
il y a dans le cadre du plan de relance
mais dans un cadre aussi des politiques
menées par le gouvernement la volonté de
décarbonés l'économie de décarbonée le
secteur de la construction est de faire
la promotion de la filière bois ce qui
nécessite de structurer la filière
plus précisément encore dans le cadre du
plan de relance une enveloppe globale de
200 millions d'euros est consacré à la
fois la création d'un fonds forêt pour
accompagner les propriétaires en matière
de diversification et de renouvellement
des parcelles mais aussi pour
accompagner la filière en matière de
plantation et et de graines ou encore
pour améliorer la connaissance
cartographique de la forêt nous allons
aller plus loin et très prochainement
deux appels à manifestations d'intérêt
vont être ouverts un premier autour de
la construction bois carbone et en 2d
autour du développement des produits
bois et des systèmes de construction
l'objectif est de permettre à la filière
bois française de s'adapter aux
réglementations environnementales en
matière de construction de bâtiments
neufs et ainsi de renforcer aussi sept
jeunes de la leur sur la filière forêt
c'est un travail de longue haleine les
réponses conjoncturelles que j'ai
évoqués prent effet tout de suite aussi
compliqué soit elle parfois à mettre en
oeuvre du fait des questions
réglementaires vous avez évoqué nous
devons aussi travailler les uns et les
autres
pour structurer la filière forêt et la
filière bois plus allant dans le temps
merci mot d'ordre est clair
ma chère collègue le seul ministre en ce
qui concerne la forêt publique des
mesures ont été prises pour garantir
l'approvisionnement de la filière
française notamment par le biais de
contrats d'approvisionnement ou de vente
labellisé de chaîne mais plus de 60% des
bois privé français sont vendues à des
professionnels qu'ils exportent à
l'international il est capital de
trouver les outils qui permettront de
réguler cet approvisionnement la france
danseuses et de tout son poids au niveau
européen pour que des mesures de
préservation de nos ressources
naturelles soient mises en place afin
d'échapper à la prédation de nos
ressources forestières et à ses
conséquences économiques et sociales qui
pourrait bien s'avérer dramatique
merci la parole est à notre collègue
annick jacques mais pour le groupe de
l'union centriste
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'intérieur et concerne le
financement des gendarmeries par les
communes
certaines communes du département du
doubs m'ont interpellé à ce sujet ainsi
que mon collègue jean françois longeot
mais ce problème se pose aussi dans
nombreux autres départements la
construction des gendarmeries est
assurée par des organismes dédiés comme
idéal ou ceux des rec kir facture
ensuite un loyer aux communes loyer que
l'état leur rembourse en contrepartie de
la jouissance des locaux au début
l'opération est équilibré en grande
partie sinon totalement
mais au fil du temps ces deux loyers
n'évolue pas de la même manière le
premier s'adosse sur un indice bt01 du
bâtiment qui augmente et le second sur
l'évaluation du service france domaine
qui déprécient les immeubles et donc
diminue les loyers de l'état au fil des
années en résumé la monte quand l'autre
descend très rapidement une différence
appareils entre le loyer demandées par
les organismes constructeurs et le loyer
versé par l'état aux communes le manque
à gagner constaté par exemple et dans
quatre communes du département du doubs
bavans béthoncourt etupes et
hérimoncourt s'échelonnent de 50 à 100
83 mille euros par an ce qui représente
pour l'une d'entre elles une perte de
plus d'un million d'euros sur dix ans
monsieur le ministre
avez vous connaissance de cette
situation si oui comment comptez-vous
mettre fin à cet effet ciseau
préjudiciable aux finances des
collectivités
pourquoi l'état ne payerez t-il pas
directement le loyer des gendarmeries
aux promoteurs
plutôt que de conserver la commune comme
intermédiaire je vous remercie pour vous
répondre la parole et au ministre de
l'intérieur sur le min
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice effectivement c'est un
problème important qui touche en
particulier la gendarmerie nationale
dont vous connaissez à la fois
l'implantation territoriale dans des
communes de parfois modestes avec des
financements qui sont modestes par
définition et puis surtout une caserne
qui est à la fois un lieu de service
public et qui est un lieu aussi de
logements des militaires ce qui rend
particulier la construction vous le
savez d'une caserne de gendarmerie
aujourd'hui il ya peu près 25% des
casernes des logements des militaires
qui sont domaniale qui appartiennent à
l'état
il yad'autres qui appartiennent
directement aux collectivités locales
et puis il ya une grande partie des
casernes de gendarmerie qui sont sous la
forme de cba cb là ils ont été rendues
possibles dans cette construction par la
dernière loi d'orientation de
programmation de sécurité intérieure et
c'est pour cela qu'une grande partie de
la construction par manque de
financement public local mais aussi
national a créé les difficultés que vous
connaissez tandis que je ne sous estime
pas mais qui peut-être est-ce complément
de votre propos madame donne à la fin de
la propriété du site à la commune ce qui
ne faut pas oublier c'est pour cela que
l'état ne verse pas directement aux
promoteurs
sauf à devenir lui-même propriétaire
alors que c'est ce que ne souhaitait pas
me semble-t-il une grande partie des
élus locaux
cependant la situation ne peut pas
continuer a duré comme cela pour trois
raisons d'abord pour les raisons
financières que vous évoquez
deuxièmement pour la raison de la
responsabilité des travaux qu'il incombe
dans ce genre de bâtiment puisque par
définition le patrimoine doit être
rénové c'est clairement ce touchant les
logements et les familles de gendarmes à
qui nous devons le meilleur respect de
l'environnement
et troisièmement parce que vous l'aurez
compris beaucoup de communes ne souhaite
pas la remise en cause de ses modèles
passent de peur que j'en à maurice s'en
aille donc je veux dire ici à la fois
qu'elles ont à murray ne sont ni radio
qu'une implantation territoriale que
dans la loppsi que je prépare à la
droite du président a répliqué du
premier ministre nous reverrons ce
système de construction notamment
pourquoi pas avec la caisse des dépôts
et ses filiales pour avoir quelque chose
qui nous intéresserait plus
particulièrement dans la sphère publique
et troisièmement que nous réglerons le
problème des baux qui sont concernés je
le fais parfois individuellement à la
demande de certains élus je suis à dire
à votre disposition il faut renégocier
ces contrats nous y arrivons souvent
même si parfois dans des difficultés
lanta n'a aucune espèce de doute il faut
payer le juste prix pour avoir
effectivement les bons travaux de
maintenance pour garder dans les
casernes de gendarmerie la famille des
gendarmes dans de bonnes conditions
mais merci monsieur le ministre je
compte sur vous en tout cas pour aider
ces communes à retrouver un équilibre
financier
vous le disiez l'implantation des
gendarmeries est importante et personne
ne veut voir ces gendarmes partir
ailleurs
mais je crois qu'il faut entendre aussi
le cri d'alarmé des élus qui ont du mal
à boucler leur budget je vous remercie
merci monsieur le premier ministre et
dalles des messieurs de vie
merci je vous rappelle que nos
prochaines questions d'actualité auront
lieu mercredi 30 juin à 15 heures
si on veut être suspendue elle sera
reprise à 16h30 pour la déclaration du
gouvernement suivie d'un débat et d'un
vote sur cette déclaration d'application
de l'article 53 de la constitution
relatives à la programmation militaire
le fiancé donc suspendu voilà pour cette
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement que vous avez pu suivre en
direct et en intégralité sur public
sénat place au des bribes de cette
séance de questions au gouvernement
et pour commencer on va aller dans la
tribune de presse de l'hémicycle du
sénat retrouver jérôme rabier jérôme
qu'est ce que vous avez retenu de cette
séance c'était un peu une séance de
questions à gérald darmanin
oui un très rude journée pour gérald
darmanin auditionné à 8h ce matin par la
commission des lois est pilonnée de
questions cet après-midi alors de ces
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
la raison du courroux sénatoriales ce
sont les dysfonctionnements dans la
distribution des professions de foi des
élections régionales et départementales
pour le groupe ps c'est jérôme durain
qui a interrogé le ministre de
l'intérieur écouter le qui l'on en croit
le ministère de l'intérieur
la responsabilité de ces
dysfonctionnements notamment celles
d'adrexo reviennent petit à à lionel
jospin petit b à la paix
petit c'est au parlement qui a autorisé
la tenue de ce scrutin par vote
et comme dans tous les bons
questionnaire plusieurs réponses sont
possibles puisque c'est la faute de tout
le monde sauf la vôtre monsieur le
ministre il reviendra à la commission
des enquêtes du sénat de définir
l'ampleur des dysfonctionnements
observés dimanche
je voulais vous poser une question très
politique à quel taux de non
distribution de la propagande électorale
estimez-vous que votre propre
responsabilité est engagée vindicte 1
contre le ministre de l'intérieur chargé
de l'organisation de ces élections après
avoir évoqué les enveloppes dans les
fossés les professions de foi brûlé
laurent duplomb interrogé gérald
darmanin sur les raisons ces
dysfonctionnements écouter après avoir
fait du a en même temps qu'ils
contribuent à donner le sentiment que
même si on élit quelqu'un ce sont
d'autres qui sont légitimes pour s'en
occuper votre fiasco de la distribution
a abouti dimanche à une abstention
record
comment comptez vous monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur stoppez votre
hold up de la démocratie le ministre de
l'intérieur a reconnu les
dysfonctionnements évoquant 9% de plis
non distribué par la poste et surtout
adrexo il a rappelé que cette
privatisation
elle avait été votée sous le
gouvernement de lionel jospin avec la
mise en concurrence était obligatoire
écouter gérald darmanin
y at-il eu des dysfonctionnements bien
évidemment qu'il ya eu dysfonctionnement
tout à fait inacceptables à plusieurs
reprises nous avons rappelé les deux
sociétés et singulièrement la société
adrexo même si le président n'a poste
lui même a fait remarquer qu'il y avait
aussi des dysfonctionnements de son côté
est principalement dans la société
adrexo puisque des pluies non seulement
n'ont pas été distribués qui peuvent
tenir à la mauvaise distribution ce qui
est tout à fait imputable à la société à
la mauvaise tenue des listes électorales
qui dépend vous le savez bien du
ministère de l'intérieur dont j'en
prends ma part mais aussi la destruction
de propagande ce qui est absolument
inacceptable
il est évident que je répondrai à toutes
les questions que se posera bien sûr
votre commission une commission denquête
qui dès la semaine prochaine devrait
auditionner les deux entreprises en
charge de la distribution la poste et
adrexo ils seront auditionnés par les
membres de la
commission des lois du sénat et public
sénat sur avec attention cette
commission d' enquête parlementaire sur
cette distribution la propagande
électorale merci beaucoup jérôme on va
continuer et bien à recueillir des
réactions de ministres après cette
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement et direction la salle des
conférences du sénat où quentin calmet
est avec barbara pompili la ministre de
la transition écologique tout à fait
alex bonjour madame pompidou ainsi de
répondre aux questions que le sénat en
direct aujourd'hui un mot sur cette
séance avec des questions venues de la
droite comme de la gauche qui dénonce et
bien le fait que le grand nord est
coupable après ces dysfonctionnements
dans la distribution de la propagande
électorale qu'est ce que vous avez pensé
c'est l'accusation sur sur les
dysfonctionnements ils sont réels et le
ministre de l'intérieur a convoqué les
prestataires pour en tirer les
conséquences le plus vite possible
d'abord pour que ça se passe le mieux
possible pour le second tour déjà
puisqu'il est encore un tour dimanche
prochain et j'appelle tout le monde
évidemment à venir voter dimanche
prochain et ensuite pour la suite les
contrats vont être dénoncés
et puis on va en tirer les conséquences
je pense qu'on ça ne peut pas se
reproduire et tout le monde en est
d'accord là dessus
après faut aussi relativiser le rapport
entre la distribution de la propagande
et l'abstention on a pu voir en
regardant sur les territoires que les
deux n'étaient pas forcément corrélés il
n'empêche que nous avons un vrai sujet
sur l'abstention
ce sujet là il doit nous interpeller
tous interpellés
toute la classe politique tous nos
concitoyens parce que c'est grave de ne
pas aller voter
madame pompili parlons du projet de loi
phare que vous portez le projet de loi
climat et résidences qui est examiné
depuis lundi dernier
ici à la chambre haute après son
adoption pas
l'assemblée nationale plutôt au
printemps elle a eu des modifications en
séance on allait prendre un petit peu
dans l'ordre vous pouvez faire un peu
quelques commentaires rapides si vous le
voulez bien parlons d'abord des zfs et
zones à faible émission ça inquiète les
sénateurs parce que pour eux il y aurait
un risque de voir un mouvement comme
celui des gilet jaune ressurgir avec
effectivement l'interdiction de certains
véhicules dans des métropoles à on parle
de 40 agglomérations d'ici le 31
décembre 2000 24 et donc ils ont un
petit peu éloignés comme ça cette date
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cet
argument sur les îles et jouer madame
conflit
je pense que c'est facile de sortir les
arguments sur rigides et jaunes
ce qu'il faut c'est d'abord regarder les
choses en face à ce qui se passe c'est
con à 40000 personnes qui meurent à
cause de la pollution de l'air tous les
ans que ça c'est très grave et que les
sénateurs veulent qu'on repousse à 10
ans l'application de la loi s'est dit
responsable
moi je veux bien tout entendre sauf que
là on est sur des causes de mort
évitable et nous devons tous lutter pour
cela les gilet jaune pourquoi c'est
arrivé parce que il considéré qu' il
n'était pas accompagné que en gros la
réforme se faisait sans penser aux
conséquences qu'il pouvait y avoir pour
eux eh bien nous notre rôle c'est de
trouver des solutions nous avons un
problème nous avons des morts de la
pollution la solution cdd feu
accompagnés
c'est à dire que personne n'ait laissé
seul face à son besoin de mobilité soit
avec des aides très forte pour changer
de voiture soit avec les transports en
commun soit avec le covoiturage bref on
met en place un arsenal pour que tout le
monde puisse continuer à se déplacer et
surtout pour ne gêner personne
mais c'est irresponsable de ne pas tenir
compte
et à rien vous deviez généralisée
effectivement leur présence une fois par
semaine dans les cantines etc
finalement les sénateurs veulent
continuer d'expérimentation vous
regrettez là encore l'apport du sénat
[Musique]
c'est un certain c'est un recul quand on
vote en avant-première articles de la
loi que nous allons respecter tous nos
engagements de baisse d'émissions de gaz
à effet de serre alors que c'est un
enfant sage de portes ouvertes puisque
nous le faisons de toute façon c'est
obligatoire nages que je vois c'est que
à chaque fois qu'il ya des avancées dans
le texte
et bien il y à des reculs qui sont
votées je trouve ça vraiment regrettable
eh bien merci merci mais les pompiers
n'avaient rien à notre micro et on vient
pour assurer bien sûr l'examen de ce
texte avec un vote final a priori le 29
juin
ici en séance du sénat on a merci
beaucoup
quentin est d'ailleurs si vous
intéresser aux débats au sénat sur la
loi climat
fovéa voir tous les articles sur notre
site internet publicsenat.fr
alors durant cette question durant cette
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
eh bien les sénateurs ont aussi évoqué
la réforme de la hache l'allocation
adulte handicapé de réforme à laquelle
s'oppose le gouvernement
le principe est simple ne plus prendre
en compte les revenus du conjoint pour
calculer la location le gouvernement s'y
oppose il a même bloqué le vote de
l'assemblée nationale la semaine
dernière pour en parler on va retourner
en salle des conférences avec quentin
chalmé qui est avec la ministre en
charge des personnes en situation de
handicap sophie cluzel est exactement
exactement alex bonjour madame cluzel
entendu ces questions aujourd'hui dans
l'hémicycle et effectivement il n'y aura
pas un d'individualisation de 7 à h les
sénateurs ont parlé d'une humiliation
pour les personnes handicapées et ils
ont repris là des arguments formulés par
les associations qui effectivement est
bien depuis quelques jours se mobilisent
pour dénoncer ce qui s'est joué en
séance de l'assemblée nationale qu'est
ce que voulait dire non pas aux
sénateurs mais aux associations madame
cluzel moi je parle beaucoup aux
associations en effet j'entends leur
revendication d'avoir une
individualisation je leur réponds
qu'aujourd'hui notre système est basé
justement sur cette famille égalisation
des revenus c'est ce qui protège
justement notre système social qui nous
permet de
ces tribus et justement et de financer
cette par exemple l'augmentation de
l'allocation adulte handicapé qui a été
de 2 milliards sur le quinquennat plus
100 euros pour chaque couple a et nous
l'avons portée à 900 euros c'était une
revendication juste est forte et je leur
dis aussi que nous corrigeons justement
certaines inégalités en réhaussant le
plafond de coupe je les ai entendus en
effet est là et nous aurons zéro perdant
avec la réforme que je porte zéro
perdant c'est à dire que les personnes
en couple qui travaille et qui sont
bénéficiaires de l'allocation adulte
handicapé ne perdront pas un centime ce
qui était le cas dans la proposition
précédente
donc c'est une mesure de justice sociale
équitable j'ai entendu aux
revendications nous avons remonté le
plafond est donc je tiens à dire
vraiment aux personnes en situation de
handicap
ne vous inquiétez pas nous continuerons
à ouvrir des nouveaux droits nous en
avons déjà ouvert et nous allons
continuer à ouvrir des nouveaux droits
pour les personnes
notre journaliste samia de chira
réaliser un reportage en avril dernier
auprès de ces personnes handicapées sur
ce sujet de l'achat la rencontrer des
personnes qui étaient et bien fragilisés
par leur dépendance à leurs conjointes
est-ce que cet argument là il ne vous ne
vous intéresse pas également
mais bien sûr qui m'intéresse bien sûr
que toute dépendance m'intéresse puisque
je travaille à l'autonomie des personnes
en situation de handicap bien sûr que
s'il ya des violences dans les coups que
ça m'intéresse et je n'ai pas attendu la
problématique de la dea conjugale
isation pour m'y intéresser et je
rappelle à toute personne qui souhaite
quitter son couple parce qu'il ya des
violences qu'immédiatement dans les dix
jours qui vient avec la caf avec la
caisse d'allocations familiales nous
avons travaillé au fait qu'elles
puissent récupérer leur achetant
l'intégralité nom ne s'est pas arrêté là
puisque nous travaillons avec les deux
réseaux et je tiens à saluer
l'engagement des associations pour les
femmes victimes de violences et les
associations de handicap qui travaillent
ensemble pour les accompagner général
question madame cluzel ya effectivement
eu un vote bloqué la semaine dernière
alors pour nos téléspectateurs on
explique ce à dire que et bien les
députés ne pouvez voter que sur un seul
texte n'y avait pas d'amendements
possibles
certains ont regretté ce qui s'est passé
à ce moment là est ce que c'est parce
que vous craignez que et bien même votre
propre majorité ne vous suivent pas et
puissent voter des amendements sur tout
ce que je veux c'est que cet amendement
abouti c'est très important pourquoi pas
ce qu'on va pouvoir le mettre en place
immédiatement et je me suis engagé que
même s'il y avait des navettes en des
textes parce qu'il faut expliquer aussi
aux autorités les spectateurs qui a des
navettes de textes et bien
le budget 2022 dès le 1er janvier 2022
cette réforme qui redistributive qui va
apporter plus de 110 euros en moyenne
dans chaque couple cent vingt mille
personnes en couple qui vont en
bénéficier
elle sera opérationnelle immédiatement
et sans perdant merci beaucoup mais
l'accusé d'avoir accepté de répondre à
nos questions en direct sur l'antenne de
public sénat
merci beaucoup quentin on va continuer à
débriefer cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement avec mes
deux invités en plateau j'accueille
aujourd'hui sur ce plateau stéphane
pieds-noirs sénateur républicain du
maine et loire bonjour jours
j'accueille également jean yves le conte
sénateurs socialistes des français
établis hors de france bonjour une
réaction sur ce qu'on entendait de la
part de la ministre sophie cluzel en
charge des personnes en situation de
handicap elle justifie l'opposition du
gouvernement à cette réforme 2d
conjugale isation de l'allocation adulte
handicapé une réforme qui prévoyait de
ne plus prendre en compte les revenus du
conjoint jean yves le conte vous
comprenez les motifs d'opposition du
gouvernement à cette réforme là on voit
que ce sont des nouveautés c'est une
opposition comptable on vient que les
arguments de la ministre sont des
arguments comptable alors que finalement
tous ceux qui veulent cette réforme
parle de dignité et de l'autonomie des
personnes handicapées et d'outils pour
cela et pour les garantir quels que
soient les revenus du du conjoint donc
voila c c c'est la marque de fabrique de
ce gouvernement une réponse comptable
une revendication de dignité ses fans
pieds-noirs l'idée c'est de cette
réforme c'est de ne plus être obligés de
choisir entre finalement se marier avec
son conjoint et avoir cette allocation
vous êtes favorable à cette réforme oui
c'est vrai cette réforme comptable et
politicienne fasse une réponse
politicienne aussi de la ministre on a
entendu tout à l'heure aux questions au
gouvernement nous dire qu'en 2018 le
groupe auquel j'appartiens aujourd'hui
elle n'était pas favorable à une telle
réforme c'est juste qu'il n'y avait pas
d' études d'impact qui était qui étaient
sur la table aujourd'hui il ya une vraie
étude d'impact rousset combien ça coûte
certes ça coûte de l'argent
mais aujourd'hui on ne peut pas dire on
peut pas demander à un handicapé de
choisir entre se marier et bénéficier de
la hache
c'est totalement inacceptable et puis on
est on est donc bien sûr dans le
registre des aides sociales mais sauf
que le handicap c'est pape s'est pas
passager s'est pas provisoire on peut
pas comparer avec toutes les autres z
sociales qui sont proposés dans notre
pays le handicap
priori ces avis et donc ça ça mérite ça
nécessite un traitement très particulier
le gouvernement avec en plus à votre
bloqué à l'assemblée le tout à fait
inacceptables justement un mot sur la
méthode le gouvernement utiliser la
technique qui est constitutionnel du
vote bloqué en bloquant le vote de sa
propre majorité à l'assemblée nationale
la semaine dernière est-ce que vous avez
été choqué jean yves le conte par cette
méthode
c'est toujours choquant parce que c'est
finalement un aveu de faiblesse
le gouvernement sait et qu'il ne sera
pas suivi par sa majorité si il la
laisse débattre mais mais mais mais
c'est bien parce que dans la majorité il
y a aussi des gens sensibles de cette
argumentation
il y a des outils pour faire de la rue
distribution mais là c'est pas un août
fin c'est un outil de dignité et
d'autonomie que qui revendiquez sur le
vote bloqué stéphane gay noir c'est un
mépris du parlement
oui on peut toujours nous objecter que
c'est contre constitutionnel c'est prévu
par les par les textes donc on peut le
faire comme le 49-3 d'ailleurs à
l'assemblée nationale c'est toujours un
aveu de faiblesse c'est toujours un
moment où on se dit on à pas on n'est
pas sûrs de nos billes quand même parce
que là le gouvernement risquait d'être
battu par sa propre majorité
parlementaire à l'assemblée nationale
avant même d'arriver au sénat enfin
c'est tout à fait c'est tout à fait
symptomatique d'ailleurs je pense d'une
majorité présidentielle qui est en train
de se de se fissurer on entendait france
auprès de patria sur votre plateau et
quelques jours dire des mots peu amènes
sur la majorité à laquelle il appartient
ça ne tient plus on voit bien ça ne
tient plus il ya des dissensions y
compris sur ce texte là on le voit bien
une majorité la république en marche qui
se fissure dans un contexte de mauvais
résultats aux élections régionales et
départementales et ce sujet il en a
beaucoup été question durant cette
séance des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement est d'ailleurs votre
collègue socialiste jérôme durain et
bien à poser une question à gérald
darmanin à propos du fiasco de
l'organisation du premier tour et de ces
professions de foi de candidat qui n'ont
pas été livrées dans toutes les communes
quand on vous êtes avec jérôme durand
est ce qu'il a été satisfait par la
réponse du ministre l'intérieur gérald
darmanin
oui tout à fait avec s'effectuant la
question j'avais posées à jérôme durain
bon
je qu'avez vous pensé de la réponse de
monsieur darmanin à votre question sur
ces dysfonctionnements dans la livraison
de la propagande électorale
bun b les un bel exercice des skiffs
toute la journée ça a commencé ce matin
en commission des lois
assez tôt dans la matinée ça se poursuit
aux questions au gouvernement
les questions étaient les mêmes toute la
journée et l'absence de réponse
identique elle aussi qu'est ce que vous
retenez combien de personnes ont pu être
touchés finalement par cette absence de
livraison de la propagande électorale
côté moi je n'ai pas reçues dans une
ville en secteur rural ça a été massif
toute la journée du vote on a reçu des
messages de personnes perdues qui
découvrait qu'il y avait deux bios
d'euros de vote parce que beaucoup ne
sont pas informées c'est des élections
qui marquent eux moins que les
municipales où les présidentielles donc
ça a évidemment eu un rôle sur
l'abstention
ça a joué un rôle majeur votre
commission à la commission des lois a va
devenir dès demain une commission
denquête en tout cas elle va en prendre
les prérogatives
qu'est ce que vous vous attendez vous
socialiste de ce qui va se passer avec
cette commission d' enquête qui doit
rentrer des travaux d'ici à la fin du
mois de juin écoutez hier il ya un sujet
immédiat de quantification de sept
tombes distribution faut qu'on comprenne
ce qui s'est passé dans les marchés dans
l'exécution des marchés et dont le
différentiel entre la peau ce théâtre xo
parce que c'est un des sujets sur lequel
le ministre a été clair
et puis je pense que soit le prestataire
privé un cas est l'un des deux
prestataires il a posté adrexo et puis
derrière c'est ces chiffres qu'on attend
et
la compréhension du dysfonctionnement il
ya aussi l'ajustement du système parce
qu'on voit qu'on arrive au bout de
quelque chose
donc il ya sans doute des conséquences
politiques en tueur et peut-être
institutionnels aussi donc ça ce sera
notre travail politique après la
commission denquête oui quelle est votre
opinion sur ce sujet est-ce qu'il va
falloir aller vers une nouvelle loi sur
le sujet ce qui va falloir revenir sur
ce qui s'est passé sous lionel jospin a
coûté en tout cas l'état ne peut pas
continuer à se déconsidérer je disais
tout à l'heure dans ma question au
gouvernement et je le disais ce matin
aussi que certains fonctionnaires des
préfectures des examens honte de ce qui
s'est passé
l'état n'est pas la hauteur sur un sujet
central pour lui les élections
donc il faut changer les choses et on a
fait les propositions des socialistes
cinq lois 30 amendements pour que on est
des modalités de vote différente aussi
donc il faut tout reprendre et on est
disponible pour ça faut juste nous
écouter jérôme murat un dernier mot avec
vous si vous ne voulez bien
il ya cette abstention record on voit
aussi dans les problèmes les dérives qui
s'est passé avec la livraison de la
propagande électorale mais c'est pas
juste ça aujourd'hui l'abstention elle
est bien plus grave que juste un
problème de livraison par la poste d'un
document n'est ce pas tout à fait il ya
un sujet de de défiance démocratique de
d'épuisement démocratique et la crise
sanitaire en a rajouté et il aurait
fallu souscrire à ce que nous proposions
et allemandes a duré de vote vote par
procuration la macro ni dans n'a pas
voulu et maintenant elle s'y rallie donc
il est temps merci ainsi jérôme durain
devrait accepter de répondre à nos
questions aujourd'hui en direct sur
l'antenne de public sénat
alex merci beaucoup quand on va revenir
sur ce dysfonctionnement dans la
livraison des professions de foi des
candidats au premier tour des régionales
avec cette audition ce matin de gérald
darmanin il a répondu à nos dom de
nombreuses questions cet après midi
stéphane gay noir vous qu'est ce que
vous pensez de ce fiasco dans
l'organisation du premier tour assez
consternant enfin le ministre darmana
lors des questions au gouvernement se
cache derrière son petit doigt nous dit
que c'est la première fois en france
qu'on qu'on organise deux scrutins sur
l'ensemble du territoire en réalité on a
en a organisé des municipales et des
comptonales hausse déjà sur un
territoire sauf que les cantonales
à l'époque c'était pas sur l'ensemble du
territoire en même temps bon ok mais
enfin en 86 ont organisé des régionales
et des législatives le même jour quand
même des scrutins aussi à enjeu en fait
la question de ce dur en est était
plutôt bonne
le dira mon amant collègues j'ai trouvé
ça extrêmement pertinent c'est jamais de
leur faute ils se cachent derrière un
tas de prétextes ont d'ailleurs le
ministre n'est pas capable de nous dire
précisément combien de combien
d'électeurs n'ont pas reçu les
professions de foi
bien sûr qu'il ya d'autres explications
à l'abstention mais les professions de
foi c'est important pour se déterminer
on peut pas on peut pas dire que la
politique c'est du marketing et se dire
on n'a pas besoin des professions de foi
moi à titre personnel je n'ai pas reçu à
mon domicile et profession de foi pour
les élections départementales
j'ai une jeune adulte à 2 à domicile qui
team dit mais comment on fait pour voter
comment on fait pour se déterminer si on
peut pas lire les programmes des
candidats tout simplement georges
lecomte est ce que gérald darmanin le
ministre des élections est responsable
de cette situation
cc c'est vous qui dites qu'il est
ministre des élections puisque
finalement fait quand on l'entend c'est
de la faute de lionel jospin c'est la
faute du parlement c'est de la faute de
la poste c'est de la faute de l'europe
il semble découvrir que des élections
qui se sont des vins il n'a pas
l'impression on n'a pas l'impression en
l'entendant qui est des élections qui se
sont déroulées depuis que lionel jospin
des plus premier ministre a fait quand
même vingt ans donc on se demande si la
personne qu'on a interrogés aujourd'hui
ministre de l'intérieur juste
commentateurs politiques fin c'est quand
même incroyable
il sait comme s'il n'avait aucune
responsabilité on a quand même alors
bien entendu on va pas mettre sur le dos
de l'acheminement des professeurs toit
l'ensemble de de l'abstention surtout en
période de pandémie avec des gens qui
ont quand même eu parfois des
hésitations à se déplacer et les
propositions en matière de vote par
correspondance balayé systématiquement
par le gouvernement mais enfin d'aider
des bulletins de vote qui sont omis dans
les allées des professions de foi dans
la poubelle brûle et dans les forêts
c'est quand même vraiment très choquant
et nous balayer ça comme ça on nous
expliquant que c'est la faute de ceux
qui étaient ouvertement il ya 20 ans
c'est une désinvolture qui qui qui met
fin de la part de gérald darmanin c'est
pas tout à fait une surprise
il va y avoir une commission d enquête
parlementaire du sénat sur ce
dysfonctionnement stéphane pieds noirs
ça va être l'occasion de trouver les
responsables à la fois les sociétés et
notamment adrexo et puis aussi dans
l'organisation du gouvernement oui dans
l'organisation on a on a pointé
d'ailleurs très tôt c'est aussi ce
qu'ils reprochaient c'est le manque
d'anticipation serre que on demandait
aux candidats au départemental 2
d'envoyer leur profession de foi très
tôt dans les préfectures trop tôt alors
qu'on sait bien que c'est ce document
s'était dit au cul âgées tout à l'heure
c'est un document qui qui donne envie à
voter au der presque au dernier moment
c'est le document qu'on prépare dans la
dernière ligne droite de l'élection pour
les élections départementales il fallait
le délivrer en préfecture très très tôt
et du coup ça n'a pas été livré dans on
ne sait pas quelle proportion de deux
foyers en france il ya quelque chose qui
n'est pas effectivement le la commission
denquête devrait pouvoir déterminer les
responsabilités en tout cas si je peux
me permettre sur le vote par
correspondance
il va falloir qu'on règle ce problème de
la distribution avant de penser au vote
par correspondance
si on imagine que les les bulletins de
vote par correspondance et est distribué
de la même façon ça aurait été un autre
fiasco encore cette fois sur le sur le
vote en lui-même
j'ai jean yves le conte on est à
quelques jours maintenant du second tour
des régionales et départementales et des
territoriales on a une abstention record
au premier tour
comment on fait pour ne serait-ce que se
mobiliser dimanche essayer de mobiliser
les électeurs au second tour avant de
penser à une réforme des institutions et
de notre démocratie
je crois que sur ses doigts des jours il
il est absolument indispensable que les
réels enjeux des compétences à la fois
des départements et des régionales
soient bien intégrés et bien dans la
tête qu'on ne fasse pas qu'on n'utilise
pas ces élections comme un sondage pour
l'élection présidentielle mais que les
enjeux et d'ailleurs ceux qui ont voté
ils ont voté pour ce à dire on voit bien
le résultat
ils ont finalement choisi souvent des
personnes pour qui voter et donner
donner une avancée des as aux sortants
considérant qu'il faisait bien leurs
biens au travail voilà donc c'est
d'abord les enjeux de ces élections et
et ne pas de ne pas faire autre chose
c'est-à-dire vraiment essayé d'expliquer
ce qui n'a peut-être pas été
suffisamment expliqué auparavant et donc
qui a qui a manqué pour que les
électeurs se rendent bien compte parce
qu'effectivement la démocratie c'est
compliqué quand il ya différents niveaux
de responsabilité pour qu'ils sachent
pourquoi il est important qu'il y ait de
voter mais sur le vote par
correspondance
oui il ya beaucoup de pays qui arrive
donc il est quand même assez incroyable
que on ya énormément de pays de voisins
italiens
le mans qui le font sans ce sens ça se
passe mal donc c'est pas la faute de
l'europe c'est juste la faute d'un
manque de capacité et de suivi de la
part du ministère de l'intérieur et
peut-être même aussi de vouloir
démontrer par l'absurde que c'est pas
possible mais ça se fait ailleurs
voilà donc c'est juste il faut il faut
juste manager ça alors messieurs cette
séance de questions d'actualité et est à
suivre sur notre antenne sur les réseaux
sociaux et également sur la plateforme
twitch où toute la séance a été
commentée par le streamer politique jean
m'assieds avec toute sa communauté genre
alors qu'est ce que les membres de la
communauté ont retenu de ces questions
d'actualité une écoute alex on a retenu
beaucoup de choses le premier la
première chose qu'on a retenu évidemment
ce sont ces échanges assez tendue entre
les sénateurs et sénatrices et le
gouvernement sur le fiasco peut-être
même le scandale de l'acheminement de la
propagande électorale avant le premier
tour des élections régionales
des échanges très tendues notamment les
questions posées par le socialiste
jérôme durain ou laurent de plomb autour
les républicains question intéressante
qui sont spécifiés temps je te cache pas
que les internautes sont un petit hâtif
sur sur le fait que des politiques
notamment les élus ou de pression sur le
gouvernement et logistique mais pour
beaucoup d'internautes notamment des
jeunes n'y a pas que ça qui est pas de
sanction donc attention à ne pas se
cacher derrière son petit bois et cder
des petits prennent du prix sema parce
qu'on reçoit une aide pas qu'on va voter
sur contourner les jeunes tu t'en doutes
donc voila mais ça reste un débat
d'intérêt par l'autre sujet qui a été
retenu c'est les changes sur
l'allocation aux adultes adultes
handicapés on s'en souvient des apports
d'eau très bien c'était bien une
pétition sur le site internet du sénat
qui avait été portée par le qui avait
rendu possible ce n'était pas sur la
location
sophie plus la ministre aujourd'hui
chères si je puis dire à prendre pour
toujours les sénateurs pour et comment
ça se fait qu'à l'assemblée nationale
son gouvernement s'est opposé à cette
réalisation était pourtant largement
internautes ça n'était pas très présente
sur la politique et on a bien posé par
gérard dont l unique les internautes en
suisse ne cachent pas qu'ils aient su
que cette paix congélation ne soit pas
eu juste voilà alex pour les 12
merci beaucoup jean-stéphane pieds noirs
cela m'amène à poser une question sur la
jeunesse je précise que vous êtes membre
de la commission de la culture et de
l'éducation du sénat dans cette
abstention dimanche au premier tour il
ya une forte abstention des jeunes 87 %
des 18-24 ans ne sont pas allés voter
dimanche comment on fait pour
reconnecter la jeunesse et bien à ce
vote ce vote démocratique
c'est un vrai sujet ont sauvé de la
réflexion tout à l'heure avec une avec
un collègue on se disait mais finalement
les jeunes depuis leur plus tendre
enfance j'ai envie de dire son nom
l'éducation civique désormais dans
l'impression que plus on vient vers eux
plus on leur propose l'éducation civique
on leur explique le fonctionnement des
institutions
et moins ils se sentent concernés
derrière en allant voter
ce résultat a pas que sur la jeunesse
mais globalement c'est cette
désaffection sur les élections c'est
c'est vraiment à la fois inquiétant et
est dramatique
en vérité pour notre pays parce qu'on ce
qu'on sait bien où ça mène ça va dire ça
va donner une une forme de l'absence de
légitimité des élus derrière parce
qu'être élu avec 30% de participation
quand vous recueillez 50 % des exprimés
c'est très faible en vérité donc c'est
ça qui est inquiétant et derrière ça
permet tout et n'importe quoi en termes
de revendication
donc il faut il faut que les jeunes se
saisissent on a on n'a pas à aller
chercher les gens pour des convictions
politiques peut-être que c'est aussi le
le nouveau monde qui dit que tout est
dans tout et que la gauche et la droite
c'est dit c'est la même chose
nous avons les différences avec avec le
collègue qui est sur le plateau mais
nous les assumons nous les défendons en
hémicycle et c'est ça d'avoir des
différences et parfois même on arrive à
se convaincre c'est ça le sait ça le jeu
politique
le combat politique c'est d'arriver à
faire à faire gagner nos convictions et
non pas un espèce de no man's land de
politique là où personne ne se reconnaît
plus de rien le en même temps c'est une
des causes
cette abstention de cette désaffection
pour pour le vote
probablement oui d'une certaine manière
je pense que c'est pas le seul 1
c'est sûr que l'on peut pas demander
enfin il n'est pas étonnant finalement
qu'après avoir vu pendant un an et demi
en période de pandémie l'exécutif
finalement considéré qu'il suffisait de
faire deux clips avec des youtube pour
remplacer une politique publique
vis-à-vis des jeunes que finalement les
jeunes se détournent de la politique
c'est assez normal vu ce qu'a fait le
gouvernement pendant un mois un an et
demi on peut de par là pendant la
pandémie ce sens pourrait m'en tenir
compte de la situation dramatique dans
laquelle était en particulier les
étudiants donc finalement l'indifférence
du de l'exécutif vis-à-vis de la
jeunesse leur envoie le rend bien mais
c'est vrai aussi que voilà avoir essayé
le théorisé le fait qu'il y avait la
raison et les méchants plutôt que de
considérer que c'était par
l'argumentation et la rhétorique et le
fait que le débat faisait naître
peut-être que des contradictions mais
aussi peut-être un peu de raison et
qu'on n'avait pas toujours quelqu'un qui
avait raison et quelqu'un qui avait tort
mais qu'il fallait débattre pour faire
sortir quelque chose d'efficace bas la
position du gouvernement de dire écoutez
nous on est on sait et puis les autres
ben c'est juste des gens qui y polémique
et qui ne font rien d'autre que
polémiquer et ben voilà
à la fin on après il ya une indifférence
encore plus grande parce qu à quoi ça
sert bien entendu tout le monde est du
côté de la raison mais peut-être
remettre le débat démocratique au goût
du jour
voilà refaire de la rhétorique du du
débat accepter que peut-être je
sortirais avec des idées un peu
différente si nous débattons sur un
sujet donné pendant une heure parce que
bien entendu c'est ça le débat pearl le
débat politique
c'était le but de cette émission merci
messieurs d'avoir été mes invités sur ce
plateau c'est la fin de cette émission
consacrée aux questions d'actualité au
gouvernement mais restez avec nous je
vous propose de suivre une audition
organisée au sénat
d'auditions de la mission d'information
du sénat sur le harcèlement scolaire et
le cyber harcèlement à les sénateurs
auditionnent les dirigeants des
principaux réseaux sociaux consacré
concernés notamment instagram facebook
tik tok et snapshot
je vous laisse écouter cette audition